le podcast est présentée par rhj cycling
association c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils commandent un podcast on les
remercie beaucoup eu ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils prennent vos vieux
appareils électroniques
puis ils les recyclent il et passe au
suivant fait pour des gens dans le
besoin
soit des étudiants car elle a besoin
pour travailler des gens qui en avaient
besoin pour travailler de la maison
phare du télétravail en ce moment on y
en a besoin santé s'entraider et part en
sorte que les gens dans le besoin plus
avoir accès à ce genre d'appareil le
pour pouvoir travailler et fonctionner
ouais
durant le premier confinement en fait il
ya eu au dessus de 1200 demandes de
matériel pour l'électronique recycling
association avec ses 1200 personnes qui
sont mis à soit étudié à la maison au
travail et à la maison qu'ils avaient
besoin de matériel électronique mais
cannes qui avaient pas accès en fait
donc allé voir ceci vous vous avez du
matériel électronique puis voulais le
passer au suivant
n'ayez crainte il assure d'effacer et de
détruire physiquement les données avec
ça veut dire que si vous avez pardon vos
mots de passe sur votre téléphone ou sur
votre ordinateur et que vous voulez
donner votre matériel sans risquer de
transmettre ces données là et ben
inquiétez vous pas pour ça vous pouvez
vous diriger au 1er à pour un ca pour
avoir plus d'information ou si vous
voulez planifier une cueillette j'ai un
numéro de téléphone ici pour vous c'est
le 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8 3
donc merci beaucoup à la gang de nous
encourager
donc c'est ce à les regarder dans vos
garde-robe un petit peu partout
s'il ya des vieux appareils
électroniques qui traîne et aussi à
votre bureau tu défends bureaux et des
ordinateurs qu'on n'utilise plus le
parent électronique bain
au lieu qui reste l'ex ou même faut pas
les jeter bien sûr on les donne à m
alors merci beaucoup qu'est ce tu voyais
une production du studio sf mais on est
au sans fil que le podcast on parle
lorsqu'on veut que vous invitez date si
tu cherches quand tu es avec moi dôme
plante le petit message pour si vous
voulez partir votre propre casse tout
amené lui que vous avez un autre niveau
on lui le studio sf s'en fait le podcast
à gmail point com pour plus d'infos
sinon dans cette semaine toujours
plaisant de discuter avec notre ami
notre amie léa clermont dion
on avait le goût de la revoir vient
d'avoir un nouveau nouvelle un nouveau
bébé une petite fille qui se séparent
kyoto d'ailleurs vous allez l'avoir
pendant qu'elle est une fille
intelligente super éloquente super
agréable à discuter on avait envie aussi
de parler de la faire
elle est pétrie où on avait beaucoup
parlé dans la dernière semaine nous
n'avait pas encore parlé son podcast
donc on voulait la dre c'est ce qu'on se
construit un juge et puis surtout en
fait de tris comme comme opportunité
comme prétexte pour ouvrir le débat sur
ce qui se cache derrière cette affaire
c'est à dire comment comment qu'on
perçoit comme un conte traite les
personnes qui dénoncent la violence
conjugale
comment compte comment conduire l'équipe
comment qu'on a parfois sans s'en rendre
compte
peut-être de la misogynie d'ailleurs
réseau ou quelque chose comme ça donc
c'était un grand plaisir d'être superbe
et conversations avec les a et s fait
que par son addiction laisser des
commentaires thomson racing sur toutes
les plateformes moi ce que vous écoutez
vous savez le tralala aussi abonnez vous
à la page piquionne ou est ce qu'après
chaque podcast on en discute dans le
encore moins de filtres sûrement trois
pierres par mois accès à tout ce fait
que sans plus attendre
bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
alors comment ça va tellement bien mais
j'ai vraiment comprendre le pouvoir
je vous écris un problème c'est qu'au
psg que vous êtes justement content
d'être le cas merci nichols maîtresse à
narbonne à mon nom mais je me suis dit
qu'il ya des fois je pense les à face à
elle 10 et pops et bondir et chaude je
pense - tu as raison tu as raison j'ai
eu 7
cette idée là qui m'a passé par la tête
l'autre fois où est ce que j'écoutais le
nouveau le nouveau clip de claudia
bouvette pire mais ce décret c'est à ses
côtés nous dit je vais prendre la peine
d'y écrire je dirais c'est à ton ton
clip parce que il ya tellement de
négatif qui nous entoure et on reçoit
tellement les messages négatifs on les
reçoit beaucoup mais de prendre la peine
de faire un check ça s'écoute j'aime ce
féliciations puis tom pyatt a tout
bloqué c'est la suite des choses
mais oui effectivement et puis on en
parlait justement pas de casse c'est
tellement d'années qui étoffent sur
plein d'affaires que 4chan du positif 2
0 oui je pense une bonne façon de l'ours
mais je pense qu'ils ont très que j'ai
changé d'attitude mois par rapport à ça
parce que je garde ça pour moi mais je
le pense et je me dis à cette évidence
gisin mais c'est si évident non puis
d'écrire effectivement ce aussi j'y fais
ce comme envoyant des projets en
entendant les gens puissent comme les
gens sont très surpris quand tu écris à
quelqu'un pour le dire hey c'est bon ce
sera votée c'est cool puis finalement
c'est positif
j'ai comme envie d'aller voir la
bienveillance aussi j'aime aussi je fais
plus maintenant qu'elle est amenée à
faire parce que je pourrai métier
mettant juste vous rendez quoi passer
pour lui je suis gardé la pensée pour
toi comme êtres l'exprimer et émettant
15 trous ton bébé qui ôte belge
je voudrais juste pour lancer un peu de
bon voilà c'est un peu de rythme mais je
pense qu'on est tellement comme dans les
polarisations que ça fait juste bien et
est d'humaniser tous aux pilotes de
sortir un peu des chicanes je dois un
peu tannique en 2020 au moins
mercure est trop grave pour s'adresser
voit la première boutique où met-on 2020
ouais vraiment mais ça a été difficile
je ne cacherai poster esther hoffe après
un long congé de maternité la mocheté
aboud obtient beaucoup mon fils mais
chez comme tu peux aller à la garderie
ça va être corée avait le goût surtout
j'avais le goût de sortir dehors j'avais
le goût de faire la fête j'avais le goût
de voir des amis tes j'avais le goût de
vie et finalement tu es comme une
semaine après qu'il commence la garderie
on venait du portugal monte chez moi
puis bon film en pis commencez à la
garderie [ __ ] moi j'étais comme je
peux pas croire je peux pas croire dans
deux semaines il va recommencer ce qui
est abou trika plus capable mais
finalement ça a été six mois plus tard
puis ou si je tombais enceinte bon c'est
une surprise
j'étais comme pas prêt pas tout seul
vraiment pop esther hoffe de m'occuper
de mon fils temps plein je vous dirais
c'est beaucoup d'énergie
puis je voulais vraiment la garderie
mais ça m'affecter moi même temps je
pense que j'ai appris la résilience
cette année beaucoup puis d'accepter
finalement ça a terminé un peu ma
grossesse avec bon avec eux le fait que
j'ai attrapé la coved a le mental qui
induirait non confinement tout seul avec
ma fille que pour elle suscitait le
summum de la marge le pet intense le
homard code je faisais cif ou lascifs
vraiment fou en irak uni dont tu l'a
attrapé après avoir accouché où je sais
pas je pense que non je l'aï appris je
les ai rattrapés avant d'accoucher parce
que en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
à une heure ou deux après avoir accouché
il ya quelqu'un qui rentre dans ma
chambre qui m'a dit excuse talk ovide
change des pierres sur la berge
je bois et métiers comme aptes à coucher
a été carrément un pilote et
physiquement à terre je venais d'avoir
une poussée extrêmement douloureuse
parce que ma fille était mal placé et
puis ça j'ai jamais lu mal de ma vie
comme ça j'ai jamais forcé j'étais
épuisée c'était pas comme mon premier
accouchement s'était plus douce mouthe
et tout puis ils m'ont juste comme je
tends chaque jeu tant chaque totale
parce que c'est que tu veux pas être que
vie des pneus parce que j'ai peut-être
contaminer des gens j'ai contenu ni tête
les tâches plus tard avant la deuxième
vague l'antre guillemets puis le fait
terminée dans une pièce enfermé avec ton
bébé qu'il y avait un ventilateur qui
montrait numonyx à 60 3 décibels je
suppose que ça veut dire mais c'est
ultra ok il trop agressant le comme
c'est à rendre full monty homme est
parti à mon avis tu es capable de façon
fallait cliquer pour ce qui est de mon
fils mais être enfermé après avoir
accouché ce cannois ouais mais deux 2
jours dans l'hôpital comme j'appelais
mais là t'as pas de contaminer tout le
monde ma compagne de ton fils qui me
prendre je pouvais pas prendre mon fils
de 18 mois je pouvais gagner un câlin à
mon charme qu'ils n'étaient pas
contaminés va d'ailleurs un bête un
câlin à son terme après avoir accouché
pendant deux semaines site of this le
sol puis c'est l'une des plus grandes
épreuves de ma vie je le dirai vraiment
simplement puis c'est pas pour faire
petit c'était un accouchement s'étoffe
de base de balma qui voit bien site of a
certain que moi akouchi le c'est pas mon
plaisir mais je peux moi je compare à
coucher puis finalement assisté comme
une grosse tape au visage puis c'est
comme résilience mal et tu es capable
mais j'étais j'ai demandé dès valium je
le dis honnêtement masqué si tu es fou
raide
après ce bain finalement ça s'est calmé
puis tout a repris son cours pilotes
n'ont même pas tout repris son cours
étrangement christ roi comme après ces
gens et on enfin libéré de tout au moins
- robin et santé des gens un peu confiné
fallu exactement à pitti de la cie les
nuits blanches plissées en se rendant
dans un autre sprint puis il ya eu un
confinement pour les parents pouvaient
pas mes parents pouvaient pas venir vous
le voir personne ne pouvait venir me
voir c'était très étrange tout ça est
étrange mais je suis ici aujourd'hui
merci mme gauche s'est entraîné ce matin
donc tout va bien
est ce que est ce que tu 5,2 besoin d'un
break même si on était en briques depuis
si longtemps
mais si le monde déroulé comme rouler
avant est ce que tu partirais un voyage
en vacances à carnon gratuitement votre
voyage pour moi pour un bouton
honnêtement parce que le décalage
horaire avec des coups d'épées ici rohff
quoique je regardais tout comme un show
le show de magalie lépine blondeau ans
et c'est chez moi
jégou m'ont jamais dit ah oui j'aimerais
bien y aller mais non par contre je
continue à travailler moi ça me fait du
bien travaillé ça me fait vraiment du
bien écrit faire des projets j'ai été
super créatif
malgré tout pas ouais ouais malgré tout
j'ai comme développer deux projets de
films jetés comme des dents pourquoi ces
besoins moi et ma créativité gones
complètement depuis le confinement jeu
plus capable de rien créé mais tombe
mais tu fais beaucoup je trouve quand
même en intervenant comme ça avec ton
près de quatre mois mais pas
nécessairement la création à proprement
parler le mouton ce qu'on fait au
podcast à gaz que oui sauf que
maintenant
plus concrètement la création notamment
sur devant mon ordi le trahissent mon
mémoire de maîtrise de ses coûts de plus
à fizi s'étoffe toi ta créativité
pendant ma captivité oui compagnon un
beat ou eskers béton moitié de la
semaine je suis dangereux 27 ont fait
des podcasts qui on travaille sur les
studios pixar puis l'autre moitié de la
semaine je travaille sur la musique
ces temps ci comme plein de projets spa
le film arrive puis c'est super cool tu
as folk confinement sama comme forcés
d'arrêter de faire ce que ça me tentait
déjà puis de parent d'enfant fait loger
plus de temps pour mettre dans des
projets vraiment créatif puis vraiment
le fun puis je travaille à un nouveau
monde que j'estime vraiment beaucoup
puis ce fut le stimulant pour le fun pak
ui-chun quant à fond quand mais je pense
ph le pauvre est il est vrai pas de
sentir que par l'état je me sens un peu
coupable chute ou le hacking de
conversation plus plate avec le ton une
mama directrice de maîtrise avec sophie
pitt s'était pas plateau sens ou l'autre
tout à fait compris qu'en ce moment il
est comme mon affaire qui se passe dans
ma vie autre que mon mémoire pile c'est
comme ça prend d'abord un peu parce que
j'ai pas de motivation là mais je me
sens pas coupable cern
parce que je sais que je vois que ça va
arriver que je vais finir sur une petite
île était pas le seul
y a plein il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'étudiants je parle de ça avec des
collègues profs puis il ya de la
détresse là pour n'en parle pas là mais
il ya beaucoup de déchets les étudiants
il ya beaucoup des traits chez les profs
qui doivent faire des zooms constants
moi aussi j'ai eu une discussion avec ma
directrice parce que j'étais comme j'ai
besoin d'ouverture c'est j'ai besoin de
souplesse parce que c'est pas facile
écrire une thèse avec un bébé entre les
jambes c'est pratiquement impossible
pythie favec durant le confinement
fallait que j'écrive le soir après tout
ma grosse journée avec le bébé c'était
très difficile l'acheter comme donnez
moi un gourou quelqu'un
je sais pas vous mais non mais tout à
fait tout à fait puis lolo de points à 7
6 6 2 je pense que tu mentionnes bien
qu'atteint 17e forcer à arrêter de faire
des choses qu'ils s'attendaient pas de
fin des fois tu sais qu'à td des
restrictions sa force à prendre des
choix des choix créatifs autour de ces
restrictions la femme et on met donc pas
de confinement petit peu je pose la
question mais tu peux continuer à faire
des shows de cover mettons dans les
bords qui a bien gagné ta vie comme ça
probablement que tu mets moins d'efforts
dans tout ce qui t'a côté que
s'attendent plus à faire exact c'est
vraiment ce d'alphonse et qu' il y avait
un conte sacrifices à faire pour libérer
du temps mais ça s'est fait tellement
malgré moi et en plus en plus d'enfants
guillemets payer pour la pcm et on peut
faire des projets créatifs qui rapporte
pas de suite puis je peux me permettre
d'arrêter de cet apport ahmad que sept
autres pirates makhoul métier 6,6 et
offs et de la remise en question
pareille de jacques le monde votre su
redevenir normale un jour aux gens ça
sera jamais comme avant parce que si
jamais comme avant en il faudra que je
me pose de sérieuses questions sont en
rien parce que toi avec l'industrie du
spectacle qui écopait la mort mort tu
sais c'est qu'en même temps c'est de
semer
non je pense que si c'est rohff c'est
rohff ou six mois je parle avec des
producteurs c'est difficile de s'adapter
à toutes les demandes de subventions que
eu à être remplis pour s'adapter pour se
réinventer je suis capable sur mon
l'oeuvre aurait mangé assez haut mais
était-ce et c'est beaucoup d'énergie en
même temps je sais pas je me tourne tout
ce qui est superflu ça a pris le bord
pis tout ce qui me je ne veux plus faire
de projets qui ne me tente pas je ne
veux plus voir des gens qui me font
chier mais je veux juste à être bien
puis seulement le confinement
un peu aidé à prioriser les choses
peut-être aussi c'est d'avoir deux
enfants comme tel depuis temps pour
signer la whey comme quand je dis oui il
faut que ça soit un vrai oui sinon je
pense qu'on vieillit j'ai effectivement
ça vient aussi avec avec leur jeu pour
elle lit les concessions que je préfère
maintenant sont vraiment vraiment moins
dommageable à ma santé mentale se disent
comment comment parce qu'avant c'était
comme dans la compétition de sport ben
pas nécessairement mais c était des fois
des fois tu vends une soirée mettons
mais ceci près que visent les métiers
des fois tu m'aides l'énergie mettons
dans une relation d'amitié qui te
rapporte pas autant de bonheur que
d'énergie tu mets ton puis des fois tu
veux faire une activité qui au final tu
attends t'es pas nécessairement d'y
aller il s'attendait pas nécessairement
d'être le puits quand tu réalises site
du crime peut-être que je perdais
beaucoup de dépassements talent avec ces
choses là qui pour moi même n'est pas
autant de positif que quelque chose
d'autre aurait pu en amener mettons
cette relation là entre les plats la
palapa la valeur d'un moment mais entre
la la plus positive que de sortir d'une
expérience versus l'énergie de suie mais
c'est comme un calcul maintenant que je
prends beaucoup plus en compte quand
j'accepte des choses qu'un jeu quand je
vois de la vente pour voir des gens d'y
faire faire semblant d'avoir une diction
personnel est intéressé par une
discussion même si à m'intéresse à
plusieurs degrés le tuer mais monsieur
plusieurs degré d'intérêt je suis juste
plus prêt à faire cette concession de
passer par exemple une soirée a pour
entretenir une relation d'amitié qui
date depuis vraiment longtemps mais qui
m'amène [ __ ] que ce qui me nourrit
[ __ ] que cela puis 9 de faire semblant
que cette relation le
ou encore la peine d'aller voir m j'ai
décidé d'arrêter de faire ça parce que
c'était trop mais justement je pense que
l'offre l'expérience font la
connaissance de soi
amen sutil au fond si quand deux vécu
des relations qui était marcel outils ou
tu es déjà fait des projets qui
nourrissait pas que du trip hop te dis
oui pour telle ou telle raison
quant aux jo cette expérience une fois
de ceux abattus le site à manille a
rendu l'âme à 29 ans mais le libre et
j'en ai choisi mieux parce que ça j'ai
déjà fait pire je sais que j'aime parce
que je sais ça fait chier puis d'écouter
aussi son espèce de petit instant parce
que tout un citoyen yoyo probable
vraiment souvent raison sinon tout le
temps qui est quelque chose qui te le
dis le camp qu'il y ait quelque chose
qui cloche avec une relation où un
projet est quelque chose qu'il dit quand
tu les écoutes
cependant des sciences puis une vie de
s'entourer juste déjà dit qu'ils
quittaient left side est entourée comme
ce clip toi tes élèves à leur tour le
texte une relation de sa couverture de
projets stimulants qui était vraiment le
goût de faire c'est le bonheur c'est fou
hein c'est drôle qu'attiser sais pas si
je ferai le monde
c'était moon c'est drôle que tu dis ça
aussi par rapport à ton à ton amitié
finalement que pris le bord j'y fais du
ménage puis je m'attendais pas seule
dans ma vie mais les relations toxique
peut importe la nature en tant que je
peux plus et projette toxiques qui est
des relations qui nous draine un peu je
dirais parasitaire j'ai pu sans vie de
ce puits en direct depuis que j'ai
vraiment décidé de faire du ménage
je m'élève effectivement puis je me sens
bien mais je trouve ça bizarre parce que
je mangeais pas comme un élément
perturbateur c'est bon c'est bien
bizarre ou mettre ses limites aussi dans
les relations professionnelles amicales
amoureuses met ses limites je pense que
ça vient avec l'âge à 20 ans je n'avais
pas cette conception là je ne savais pas
ce que ça voulait dire pis si je mettais
mes limites c'est peut-être tout croche
mais ça me j'ai trouvé ça difficile
assumer seul j'ai eu beaucoup de
culpabilité par rapport à à ses
relations la oca jimmy fin mai un moment
donné j'ai été j'ai deux enfants qui
monte charge et mes amis proches et ma
famille ici beaucoup j'aime y passions
puis je peux pas comme m'investir dans
nos relations à moitié on dirait et
fibre ftc
si je suis ici c'est aussi parce que
j'ai envie d'être logés vraiment comme
montrer que ma tête du moment présent
trimestre un peu cucul mais c'est vrai
si c'est sûr comme pour moi le
confinement à travers la dernière année
qu'avec tout ce qui se passe au site
envoie une monde pierre ya tellement eu
des amants de la gamme malheur je pilais
mamitu m'a vraiment perturbé socialement
individuellement jeu moins qu'un cas
contre reçu la promesse faite deux ans
c'est le
le mythe ou semi c'est maintenant la
première vague en confectionnant c'est
simplement foncé pour parler nous depuis
la vague de dénonciations sur les
internets puis sauter ça ça a été un
espèce de deux gros gros écoles pour ben
du monde puisse mais ça l'a été aussi
extrêmement anxiogènes pour pratiquement
tout le monde ça l'a été
ouais c'était un essai de répit en fait
j'ai l'impression que cette fois-ci tout
le monde s'est senti concerné parce que
la première fois
la première fois c'était comme ok
certains intouchables une personne tombe
mais c'est encore un peu loin de nous
moi j'ai pas tellement d'introspection
affaire c'est vraiment certaines
personnes importantes pouvoir qui tente
qui était problématique de ce cas là
c'est comme ça peut arriver à tout le
monde qui tout le monde
une introspection afin de fixer vraiment
c'était vraiment plus confrontant ces
taxis beaucoup plus beaucoup de colère
beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup de
déception autour de nous un c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'était gros le mythe ou
un mail me tous deux au québec en tout
cas c'était vraiment j'ai croisé du
monde il va avoir des malaises parce que
tutelle go ou tel gaudens dans
l'industrie musicale est beau et ça y
est allé un grain et ça va parce que
lorsque tu as un fokker m'écoute la
première fois que j'entendais ce genre
de comportement quelque chose que nous
on excusez l'expression rennais mais pas
vraiment pas ça ne veut pas dire son nom
mais mais qu'est ce que c'est quoi ta
question j'imagine dit non mais oui dans
ce sens est confronté effectivement j'ai
des discussions avec 10 à 12h
moi je connais du monde qui ont été
ciblés par par le mouvement mais
j'imagine que tout le monde connaît du
monde qui ont été ciblés et j'ai eu des
discussions avec ces gens là bas nous
tous mais certains parce que je trouvais
important de bennes de confronter d'y
aller et de pourquoi de comprendre
comment je pense que dans une dans une
volonté de changement réel puis je pense
qu'il ya vraiment des discussions qui
ont eu lieu qui aurait jamais eu lieu
sur la paternité toxiques sur les
violences et toupie il y à il ya des
gens qui je pense sont dans les
processus de re questionnements profonds
thérapeutique chip cox josas que c'est
vrai et je dis pas que ça marche du box
mais je pense qu'il y en a aussi que oui
ça va faire du bien quant à 18 ans je
m'excuse total adolescents quasiment
puis moi je crois à l'éducation beaucoup
je crois qu'il faut écouter les victimes
il faut pour s'éduquer pour sensibiliser
mais il faut aussi alors ordonné en
parler avait ouvertement puissant
nécessaire moi comme je sais pas comment
mon limoux ici sont difficiles à
utiliser dans les câbles de façon
adéquate de métier je veux pas condamner
nécessairement je peux prendre par la
main des ados c'est essayer de
travailler tous ensemble à voir que ça
soit trop tard puis conçoit avec un que
comme gilbert rozon pour ne pas le
nommer ou d'autres vieux vicieux qui
visiblement n'ont rien compris je pense
qu'on peut évoluer et puis ça passe
beaucoup par le dialogue je crois dans
l'humanisation de tout sauter certains
vieux coq tu dis maintenant quelqu'un
comme monsieur barroso j'ai l'impression
c'est quelqu'un qui apprendrait jamais
été je pense que je pense qu'il va être
capable de
d'apprendre de changer puisque ségolène
jeu était en cours le oui bâcle selby
continuer dans ce sens qui déjà sont
irrécupérables je pense que la grande
majorité des gens sont récupérables une
réalisation possible si un travail sur
soi qui est fait je pense que tout le
monde s'entend je pense la majorité des
gens sentant que le mouvement dans la
manière qui s'est déroulé il ya
certaines dérives possibles type n'est
pas optimal mettons c'est normal
optimale sauf que c'est complètement con
prenable est nécessaire pis le fait que
ça soit aussi gros c'est vraiment la
preuve qu'il ya un problème vraiment
profond de société omniprésent cette
affaire juste ça fallait que ça explose
parce que le step est capable de rester
confinés 2009 a explosé sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'était la seule place
la seule manière qu'on pouvait
s'exprimer il ya beaucoup de souffrance
en fait je réalise 7 c'est finalement
des comptes dénonce peut-être qu'il ya
aussi tout un bagage de vie toutes
sortes d'expériences qui font en sorte
qu'on en arrive le typique on dit on
n'est plus capable le presto à sauter
puis si c'est lourd d'un bagage pas
toujours joyeux finalement de
comportement qui était autrefois
banalisée pour moi lille le monde a
changé en quelques années ici parfum
cité il ya pas longtemps dans un gala de
l'adisq que je veux dire c'est st rock n
roll et pis c'est plus que c'est plus le
code il ya des actes qui se sont
déroulés dans le passé qu'ils méritaient
d'être nommé pis c'est pas tous qui a
été nommé non plus mettre en cause de
calais on a vraiment un problème dans
nos comportements pi et je trouve ça
positif quand même qu'il ya eu de cette
colère là qui est exprimée puis ce
ressenti leur qui était qui était lancée
au visage finalement 2 to speak tant
mieux parce que on peut comprendre cette
colère et cette tristesse lost désarroi
parce que
il n'y a pas de ya pas vraiment de
moigné adéquat en ce moment pour se
faire justice pour obtenir justice et le
système de justice et pas dé quoi en ce
moment on a beau lui les procureurs se
défend bien de seul dpcp dit bien que
non non ça fonctionne mais attention il
ya des gros problèmes système est qui
qui sont réelles puis je dois site est
une victime d'un grain ou en gaspésie te
pas nécessairement goût d'aller en
justice et pas nécessairement ce la
solution face au grain et de ce monde
non merci ça tarde vraiment de d'aller
dans ce processus ce qui est très très
longs et souvent au city avec d'un dans
le mythe ou par tous ce qui était
dénoncée c'était des actes qui qui était
qu était inacceptable puis de déplacés
mais pour ce genre d'accueil c'est pas
tout le monde qui est prêt à
entreprendre des mesures judiciaires
aussi justement pour grainé envers le
sait c'est inacceptable de grenay
inverse sauf que tu fais granit ont
ouvert tôt pas envie de s'embarquer dans
une est histoire infini le stage devant
les yeux devant un jury tout petit même
chose pour ben histoire qu'on visait pas
ce que tu fais c'est inacceptable mais
je peux comprendre vraiment la personne
ne pas vouloir la victime de pôle nord
embarqué dans des procédures qui
finissent plus prudents alors que la
camtel si traumatisant mais pas de
possiblement que tu es capable de passer
à autre chose parce que sinon en fait
c'est quoi le processus de justice comme
tel c'est ce qu'est ce que ça implique
selligent la maison veulent peut-être
peut-être porté plainte le premièrement
faut que tu trouves le poste de police
le plus près de chez vous tapez est due
à qui bon j'aimerais porter plainte
suivent eux le policier reçoit ta
première charge la première décharge
comme un peu comme tu veux tu donc le tu
témoignes une première fois après selon
l'enquêteur éventuellement ça peut
prendre quelques semaines si tu as entre
connu un enquêteur qui vient de
rencontrer qui prend ton témoignage le
t'explique ce que tu as vécu et que
j'étais roig noter tout ça va être
utilisée avant tuellement que les gens
le savent pas nécessairement quand il
parle de gaza
cinq sens à 100 sa soeur m'étouffer
noter que ça peut être retenu contre toi
après cette attente attente attente le
tut tut le dpcp qu'il est directeur des
poursuites pénales et criminelles qui
donc la couronne de la reine
d'angleterre
ils vont retenir ou bottes à plainte il
à partir de là ça peut prendre encore
plusieurs mois voire années avant
d'avoir une enquête préliminaire qui
vise finalement a souvent aller en cours
et témoigner devant un juge devant ton
l'agresseur tu vas te faire contre
interrogé par l'avocat de la défense de
ces la première étape avant le procès
c'est ça dure une journée a besoin duré
une journée après ça tu peux attend 2 en
1 une a3 il ne te le procès lille peut
durer des semaines où je te fais
interrogées contre interrogé devant ton
agresseur il te fait questionner sur ce
qui s'est passé
donc quand on entend que l'avocate
l'avocat de la défense de roseaux à dire
la plaignante combien de bouteilles
avaient sur ta chemise bcd question
qu'on peut se poser
donc le site une joute oratoire c'est un
peu comme un jeu d'échecs piloter comme
quelqu'un dit oui devant toi puis tu le
détruit encore peu c'est finalement
c'est un peu une victimisation et après
c'est un tel verdict puis ça peut
prendre six à fait prendre des délais de
paiement lobby c'est beaucoup d'énergie
d'anxiété et j'ai oublié de nos mais
aussi le camp si le dpcp retire après
une belle ils vont arrêter l'agresseur
comme tel et vont l'arrêter chez eux que
ça fait comme ça peut faire un scandale
et cetera puis tu peux avoir des
contrecoups de ce si l'on ne veut pas
découragé les jamais cessé si belle
s'est fait en fait c'est ce qui explique
cela s'est clairement prononcée
clairement la raison principale pourquoi
des mesures comme des dénonciations
publiques sur des réseaux sociaux sont
sont arrivés l'été
oui parce que c'est tout ce que tu
décris l'est qui peut prendre jusqu'à 3
tu as créé les tons vert ça se peut que
tu as vraiment pas envie de faire ce nom
se sont appuyés différents niveaux le
jeu par ce qui était alors la peine peut
être de porter plainte
dépendamment de la rrq sauf que c'est
une grosse partie tu habitais 4,18 à 3
ans tavi dédia santé même si les temps
d'attentes là dedans je dirait l'autre
c'est loeb 6 3 dans ta vie que tu dédie
à ce que tu vis pas pleinement l'intrus
que je pense que 18 ans à 20 ans médecin
peut importe l'argent fait envie de
vivre pleinement du fespo stigmatiser
mais par les systèmes comme tel qu'un
procureur il ya aussi des étapes que
j'ai pas mentionné mais le procureur va
être amené à rencontrer pour t'expliquer
tout tout le modus operandi puis le
rôle-titre sûr tu es tu vraiment faire
ça ça va être grave ça va être difficile
ça va être top
es-tu prêt à cela le qatar va faire le
même processus au site ses fils et c'est
vraiment comme ça doit être
déstabilisant pour un jeune qui veut qui
veut obtenir justice mais qui se
retrouve dans un système tellement lourd
puis impressionnant jeudi en arrivant
colloque dans un interrogatoire comme
tel tu regardes les victimes de
témoigner là c'est extrêmement
intimidant comment se fait-il que ton
agresseur est à un mètre de toi petit
regard en voyant c'est ça n'a pas de bon
sens je ne comprends pas pourquoi
l'agresseur est à côté puis qui
regardent voyons donc c'est pas un lieu
sûr pour témoigner n'est pas acceptable
pour moi c'est pas des conditions qui
sont clémentes et bienveillante pour la
victime
donc tous ceux et seront pas de
criminels c'est ici donc gratuit
mais si on veut aussi véloce et des
frais ça c'est dit coupet puis tout ce
processus judiciaire law criminel c'est
tuer la preuve c'est éviter une
agression sexuelle donc si ta parole
contre celle de l'autre point et il faut
que la preuve soit vraiment comme pardon
c'est ça c'est hors de tout doute
raisonnable il faut que la démonstration
soit faite et que le juge n'ait aucun
doute que ta parole faut plus que l'on
se donne à fond
c'est extrêmement difficile si c'est
vraiment vraiment offs et
c'est très difficile alors je comprends
moins les filles qui ont vu leur verse
affaires graines et des bagarres sais de
quoi je vais dénoncer anonymement
ça va faire plus de bien ça va être plus
rapide ça va être immédiat puis je
comprends ce en même temps je comprends
les gens qui disent oui mais on a un
système de justice il faut y contribuer
et d'eramet
mais c'est très facile de dire tout
juste à porter plainte juste à porter
pâle non c'est pas juste sur six et dix
années d'investissement c'est des coûts
matériels économique ces découpes
psychologique ici pour ce mois je crois
que ça a été aussi gros l'odyssée cet
été parce que si on était confiné puis
c'est plus facile aussi un dépôt croire
nos trois époques les gens ne voudraient
industrie de la musique les chanteurs
chanteuses il se voyait pas
il savait que il croiserait patel d'o2
au festival de st je pense qu'elle sera
unifié même chose avec ses lacets les
réseaux sociaux les la scène des
influenceurs hangi mail ou est ce que
c'est qu'un hacker mais tu sais que tu
es croate bat pas au shag dans le vip le
tout ce monde là je pense aussi que le
confinement la co-vedette aussi ce par
hasard si autant de mouvements sociaux
en cette année c'est à cause que comme d
d d d une situation qui en guillemets
favorise le tir je pense que le fait et
mettons le fait que le mouvement black
is murder suite à la mort de thatcher
était aussi au prix autant d'emplois
parce qu'elle est on avait le temps
s'indigne on avait le temps de la
regarder la vidéo on avait le temps de
trouver que ça pas de bon sens le temps
de d'en parler ce réseau sociaux qui
sait ce qui je pense que c'est vrai pour
le mouvement dénonciation je pense que
c'est vrai pour pour plusieurs choses
c'est par hasard si si tout ça arrive
même table 2020 nous paraît aussi
horribles en fait des choses horribles
on est tout le temps déroulé c'est juste
que l'on non on le voit plus et on les
fait mon album bleu sont le fruit ce
saut si on le filme on en parle
on a des débats de société autour de se
taire ou des rendu un débat société
parce que tout était on en est on y est
dit dans ce mode là mais en même temps
c'est difficile ça fait mal mais si
nécessaire je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est
là que ça se passe vraiment mais je
pensais vraiment effectivement concours
de circonstances historiques finalement
mai mais ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
avec 30 et bien on est conçu les aimez
mais dans quel monde vivons nous c'est
sûr que ça a été un des facteurs qui a
créé tous toutes ces révoltes sociales
parce que c'est le blocage mardi c'est
tout là toute la communauté noire deux
uniques qui baigne pas tout mais une
grande majorité de la communauté noire
qui qui qui trouvait qu'il voulait
trouver une façon de changer le
paradigme parce que parce que ça ça n'y
est pas bon c'est quand même quatre
autres années trente pièces et c'est là
c'est la fin des ethnies comme on le
connaît déjà cité on en a parlé beaucoup
le team et de gestion cng va la pire
chose pour lui c'est qui il divise
encore plus puis je pense qu'on en est
là ça a été de monde qu'en fait acquis
non le faux faux qui a quelque chose
qu'il faut quelque chose change pis
vidéo de 8 minutes d'un gars qui se fait
tuer en live sphère qui non ça va être
un catalyseur de de momentum puis comme
de fait c'est ce que s'est passé le
style de faire sortir le vote parti
c'est tout le monde est allé voter tout
ce qui fait que l'on va enfin libéré
jeudi son bureau a tout de même paul
salaün effet je pense que justement
l'espèce le tropisme une espèce de sale
se lave en effet le tromper frederik
gagnon la chaire raoul dandurand
s'il est exceptionnel et la fête jacou
slayer fallait même pas non l'action
ensemble c'est drôle comme des gens qui
l'adorent puis d'autres noms communs y
allant d'un vendeur de chez moi j'ai
apprécié ce qu'a à dire bon teint mat et
comme j'ai tu pour te rend plus dé gide
non non il est pas bon train pendant
tout mais non c'est un bon analyste je
suis d'accord mais faudrait gagne on
sait que moi j'étais étudiante à le cam
je l'écoutais parler j'ai été subjugué
par son éloquence et je le trouvais
vraiment pertinent comme vraiment pili
plus la sensation horrible on a
tellement de messages après que ce soit
me bertin qu'ils aillent c'était mon
prof puis j'ai capoté
mais tout ça pour dire que tu mets ton
tant qu'à moi mettons les maux de notre
société en ce moment c'est la
désinformation c'est un des grands maux
de notre société
puis les télés le ski amène aux
conspirationnistes pitt ceux qui la
polarisation tirer le fait qu'on ne
connaît pas capables de se parler de
dialoguer car on est dans des camps
différents pitié de la personne la plus
puissante au monde finalement triki qui
au lieu d'essayer de combattre se
jettent de l'huile sur le feu pitié est
un acteur de désinformation de
polarisation de ces faits qu ici on
dirait que au lendemain d'élections
guidance était vraiment juste un feeling
parce qu'ils aient en réalité técély ces
choses ne changent pas du jour au
lendemain mais le lendemain d'élections
buydens est comme on dirait que l'été
qui est comme le climat est plus ils
m'ont attendu déjà de journal m que moi
je me sentais même j'ai montré qu'on
était quatre en force et noir et or ont
forgé tout le temps pour tout le reste
est stressé before j'ai l'impression que
à ok au lieu des 4 as est encore ou si
forget buteur
on pouvoir respirer un peu plus puisse
parler un peu plus pis juste parce que
c'est un flow a représenté mais oui et
puis le développement de la pensée
complotistes est extrême et tout à fait
surréaliste je veux dire le cul end
quand ça a commencé moi je t'ai comme
mais c'est une c'est d'une nullité c'est
nul c'est mme comment est-ce qu'on peut
tomber dans une telle idéologie comment
est-ce qu'on peut concevoir réellement
la queue que quelques obama pourrait
être potentiellement leader d'un groupe
pédophiles sato satanistes je ne conçois
pas c'est de l'irrationalité évidemment
trump ron pour qu'ils encouragent et
quelques en quelque sorte le finalement
meetic comment est-ce que cette pensée
de l'extrême qui finalement est
littéralement irait mais je dirais de
l'hérésie le comment est-ce que ça
puisse développer pis je crois pas je
veux pas tomber dans le déterminisme
technologique
je pense pas que mettons les réseaux
sociaux créés line je pense que c'est un
outil pour promouvoir la haine
par contre j'ai l'impression aussi que
les réseaux sociaux ont pu contribuer
largement c'est peut-être une évidence
et un lieu commun de le dire mais assez
pensé la génération y des alexis que
cette trudel qui sont tout d'un coup
très populaire ben je m'excuse mais les
réseaux sociaux ont vraiment eu un rôle
à jouer là-dedans
dans cet homme dans cette absence de
sanction de la parole j'irai parce qu'à
un moment donné il faut encadrer
il faut encadrer la liberté d'expression
oui mais ça peut être dangereux même au
delà de ce commence comment se fait-il
qu'un individu peut adhérer une telle
idéologie limite secteur c'est qu'ils
présentent cette pratique celle du bien
c'est quand du secteur c'est que ça on
s'en retourna à l'origine des religions
ou est ce que tu cherches des réponses à
des questions que tom may que les
réponses existent pas avec toutes les
critiques
puis là c'est beaucoup de monde qui sont
à attendre confinement qui sont censés à
plein de niveaux le dessus au niveau
psychologique au niveau monétaire déjà
qu'ils comprennent pas pourquoi leur
business ferme pour qu'ils comprennent
pas pourquoi ils y ont plus d'argent
pour payer pour leurs familles qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils voient justement
leurs enfants
avec pris dans ce tournoi qui commence à
se dire ok mais moi je j'ai besoin d'une
certitude
parce que si j'ai pas de certitudes
c'est absurde le fait qu'un étudiant qui
propose une certitude comme celle là qui
somme toute très confortable parce que
le problème est créée par l'homme est
pas un problème qui est incontrôlable
mettons le comme c'est la cas vis du
site ici khadr au fait que la coved a
été créé mais tombe pas avec des idées
derrière de vouloir propager ce partout
un monde que la chine devienne par
exemple la domination mondiale qui
m'incite à bord assure au moins c'est
concret puis ça peut très conforter
parce que tu sais c'est quoi la source
du problème que de tous tes mots dans ta
vie les solutions mais c'est aussi la
base du populisme êtes les solutions
simples à des grands enjeux un certain
moment donné quand tu regardes un enjeu
qui trop complexes ainsi très rassurant
pour le cerveau humain et pour l'humain
de trouver des solutions simples pour
expliquer les grands mots parce que
sinon on sombre dans une grande
dépression dans une grande tristesse
dans un désarroi total
puis je pense qu'il ya peut-être je
trouve ça intéressant ce que tu dis même
s'il mange pas spécialiste du tout de
surf devriez interviews et martin
geoffroy sur les questions de la
radicalisation le clip très pertinentes
qui s'est intéressé d'ailleurs aux
sectes à la base puis voyait justement
ces mécanismes psychologiques et
faiblesses les venir habiter écologique
des gens qui allaient vers des pensées
extrême gérard bonheur aussi
s'intéressent à cette question de la
pensée de l'extrême son livre à lire
vraiment intéressant puis il y voit un
peu les parallèles psychologique de
cette venir habiter dont tu parles
alexis cossette trudel d'ailleurs est un
bon candidat
enfant de la révolution d'octobre
quelques parties de file kyste qui avait
10 absolue dans l'entité dire a dit cool
qui avait la pensée absolue faisait
partie de leur vie mais on dirait que ça
me donne pas vraiment non plus qu'il
aille vers une autre extrême puis aussi
ont besoin de romans tease à sion là des
choses dans l'est je trouve qu'en 2012
entre que moi j'ai côtoyé des gens que
je trouvais que des voleurs pensée
extrémiste
al'inverse 7,7 grand idéal de société
qui on avait besoin
révolutionner le monde puis de penser
aux grands récits c'est inspirant sauté
du sis lauriers c'est peut-être ce qu'il
espère pourquoi comme tu t'en vauvert
ceci je pense que oui l'effet du commun
aussi à force d'être isolé dans notre
maison à porter des masques
alors que des jeunes donc la vie commune
s'est considérablement effrité dans les
dernières années
peut-être que ça c'est d'avoir
l'impression d'avoir un groupe éphémère
oui je pense qu'on est des animaux se
sont entre guillemets tiens on a besoin
des gens autour de nous puis peut-être
que ces gens là qui sont plus
vulnérables vont vers l'autre de cette
façon là puis de ce grain qui aussi
contre un ennemi si rassurant c'est si
rassurant ces mêmes grisant un certain
moment c'est d'abord un ennemi
politiquement c'est leur gamin poli
canadien ritchie tahiti ça non mais pour
vrai que je peux mettre ma les partisans
du canadien
qu'est ce qui faut il charles sur quoi
là je sais pas non mais pour et gèle ses
projets ses palais des sports la
médecine les phénomènes secteur est
toujours existé qui je pense que céline
et même une chose qui pousse une
personne à derry justement d'un même
secteur kaki au henan quoi ou où ce
genre de théorie le sauve que goethe à
masquer les réseaux sociaux permettent
c'est la porte et que ça peut avoir le
jeter raël il ya un certain nombre de
gens imaginent si elle était sur twitter
déchirer comme sauf que là c'est ça
c'est qu'il n'y a plus de limite au
nombre des personnes qui peuvent être
infectés ou trois enfants c'est comme ça
c'est un virus se répand comme disait
c'est comme la cabine mais c'est infect
ton esprit hippie je pense aussi qu'il
faut se pencher pour trouver le vaccin à
ce virus à
gif animés tu parles tu parlais de la
liberté d'expression la doit à tout prix
tantôt puis ça pourrait nous amener à
parler de ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine avec avec la sphère et les abbés
tribaux des bonbons mais mais ouais en
fait c'est ça moi je vienne québec
convient québec pis québec les radios
poubelles mais ç'a toujours été une des
choses que je détestais le plus c'est
celle là c'est probablement la chose que
je déteste de québec tss québec sq à ma
ville préférée sauf sur ce climat là
mais des gueules puis place laurier ces
malades le bolide le terme ashton non
mais il y avait son devoir
moi aussi j'ai vécu à québec a pas ça
même ceux qui portent un nom ça se
connaissaient pas si ça existe encore
fermée c'est le fun parce que c'était
vraiment mais ceci dit oui donc les
ratures pour ces sceptiques qui
revendique énormément la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'expression
c'est une chose mais après ça quand tu
prends l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé à
que ben radio avec la sphère de lisa
betriu tu peux pas juste tout dire sous
prétexte que c'est la liberté
d'expression c'est pas parce que tu as
un micro que tes potes que tu peux tout
dire
donc c'est un mec heures quand ça arrive
puisque là on les surprises
est ce qu'on est vraiment surpris que
ben radio non trend en bout quelqu'un du
web sans savoir de quoi il parle
le tout le monde fait qu'un mot ma
gueule geneviève pire chaîne à l'hadopi
est ce que vous êtes vraiment surpris
non parce que ce problème le long
on lui connaît depuis tellement
longtemps tellement longtemps
puis il ya personne qui dit rien
personne ne fait rien on va juste
continuer à entretenir ce entretenir la
liberté d'expression sur tout les médias
puis de jamais remettre en question ça
fait ça crée des structures de
restauration à ces gars là puis moi je
la comprends cette frustration le et
pour répondre à ta question je ne suis
pas surprise parce que je lis je les
écoutais beaucoup que ben radio et
pourquoi pas son genre quelques dans une
démarche de de comprendre ce que les
autres ont à dire qu'ils pensent pas
nécessairement comme moi je me disais
bon set radio l'un des porte paroles qui
visiblement adapté à une perspective
plus à droite puis je fais attention à
ce que je dis pas ce que c'est pas vrai
que c'est tout le monde mais maintenant
richard martineau ce moment dit que
peut-être un peu plus de centre-droit
puis c'est correct et j'ai beaucoup
écouté toutes les émissions là pour
vraiment comprendre qui en fait ça m'a
amené à les humaniser mais ça ment aussi
amené à constater qu'ils avaient des
dérapages
malheureusement je vais le dire
honnêtement j'ai été surprise d'entendre
des propos surtout dans la bouche de
geneviève peterson à son émission qui
concerne les influenceurs et de manière
générale je trouvais que c'était un peu
inapproprié dans certain côté je dirais
on est prêt à beaucoup de monde pas
juste
elisabeth riou jeudi à parler de toi par
les mains du monde puis dimanche à
marmaris puis me dit ah ben coudon c'est
peut-être c'est pas un ton qui est
valable mais moi ça me faisant un peu de
dpn j'étais comment pourquoi facile
c'est trop je veux pas personnaliser le
débat paraît pas ce cap avant ses
opinions et tout mais je ne suis pas du
tout été étonné on en parlait souvent
comme des phénomènes de foire des
lanceurs pas ce qu'avait fait un film là
dessus puis je connais ce alors je vais
vous en parler alors moi quand c'est
sorti j'ai trouvé ça dégueulasse mais
j'étais pas étonné non plus est le droit
à l'erreur puis
il va falloir que va falloir qu'on
avance mais mais c'est très
représentatif
on retrouve d'une pensée se voit team
faut pas l'être par les radios poubelles
je pense que cette semaine en est la
preuve que c'est pas un phénomène
exclusif à québec
non non non ce qui est témoin que le
temps qui est employé le sont tant que
j'ai entendu toutes les fausses à mon
char le médecin légiste lyon la cendre
amenez-le ses sept niveaux you c'est ce
niveau là de par ses petits des baux
type 6 qui skie triste effectivement pis
c'est sur ses pieds en plus de critiquer
quelque chose de dénigrer quelque chose
puis que de ton propre aveu qui connaît
pas surtout en chine dit c'est quoi
jeudi 4 à 10 je connais pas se plie pas
cinq minutes 12 minutes dagès bâches et
ce après avoir dit la première phrase je
connais pas exclu qu'à faire honnêtement
de moi je suis capable
ce n'est pas schindler et franchement on
peut arriver à autre chose sincèrement
je suis écoeuré et je pense que beaucoup
de gens de notre génération aussi le
libre bon j'ai vu plein de gens sur
instagram les influenceurs être bête
année puis je pense qu'on peut tout
changer de sujet c'est correct
on a compris le message mais on va
donner je t'avais un cube radio pixels m
interviewer père faisait moins toi tu es
féministe mais maquillée
ça se peut que tu vraiment clair elle
essayait de trouver comme des confettis
comme riz 2020 puis on est là dans
discussions qui jettent et si je dis que
non le jeu plus capable de ce genre de
discussions le pour moi c'est
contre-productif
si tu n'es pas bien dans ta peau c'est
correct willer mais ce n'est pas
d'inspirer public ça ne fait pas de sens
on mélange tout comme isabelle rioux ont
mélangé tout le jeu dire c'est une
victime de violences conjugales sept
fils un bébé de quatre mois quatre mois
puis je dire les photos sont d'une
violence
est-ce qu'on peut exprimer de l'empathie
est ce qu'on peut exprimer la
bienveillance ce n'est pas le moment de
parler de son corps mais oui mais titre
sur sa plateforme aussi celle ci serait
grave
tout le moment ce qui est vraiment un
moment pour faire sauf not enough est
vraiment ce qu'elle veut c'est un homme
et en avant la discussion qui une façon
de faire des quelque chose parce que
t'es pas d'accord avec la manière dont
ces faits dont livre avec les valeurs
jeudi on a encore le droit je pense de
ce crédit qui s'était clairement pas un
bon timing nos sens que sûr que le
timing n'était pas un hasard qui sait le
parler si elle a parlé de son corps puis
de la manière de
c'était quand même assez violent
l'american apparaître seppi c'était je
peux je resterai à coucy à whistler
tout ce matos et violence non pays
réputé jeu je pense que tout a été dit
ou presque là dessus puis je veux pas
taper sur le clou je pense que j'ose
espérer qu'elle a compris puisqu'elle
n'a pas compris qu'on prendrait jamais
dans ce sens que c'est je pense qu'ils
allaient contre josé pérec avait compris
que le fait de pas correct sauf qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent comme elle
puisse à ces problèmes à ses côtés sauf
que le fait que cal amène une discussion
sur le fait qu'à cas pour des photos
d'elle en maillot de bain que quelques
cas ce film qui affirme son accouchement
tous ceux au moment qui a pas de
violence conjugale ben c'est une manière
d'aider kribi décrédibiliser son sa
sortie son disco de discipline en fait
le sous-texte de te quitte à les hanter
link pour ce qu'elle a dit mais c'est au
final ben une certaine date le peut-être
chercher tes potes c'est gros ce que je
dis métier dans ce sens ok which is in
the way mais par dessus tout c'est le
nouveau
c'est une boucherie tine de guerre
allait de soi ok c'est le nouveau quel
genre de photos du prochain star grammes
c6 s'étaient quittés vite et une
médication mais qu'est ce qui portait la
longueur d'état je peux c'est quoi si
puisque pour finalement mettre le blâme
sur la femme sur la victime plutôt c'est
la vraie vie c'est ce qu'elle fait
depuis elle dit que c'est parce qu'elle
fait mais c'est ce qu'elle a fait c'est
ce qu'à la fête puis c'est très très
répandu puis vous avez reçue juliette
bélanger carpentier qui est spécialisé
dans les questions de victimologie pis
souvent quand une victime de violence
vaut porter plainte
il ya un processus de il ya souvent un
phénomène de hop on joue ma petite fille
prénommée mi temps situé à l'est merci
ça râle donc s'essayer à un phénomène de
victimisation qui parfois pire
attendez je sais par exemple à
victimiser donc ce que je voulais dire
c'est la victimisation c'est de remettre
en question la parole la victime en la
dénigrant et en lui refusant revit
finalement une la violence parfois c'est
pire donc moi j'ai l'impression que
comme eu il ya eu ce aussi tuées dans
dans ce qui a été dit par joseph
peterson ça nous faisait revivre ce
qu'on vit car comme victimes ont porté
plainte
puis quand comme victime on ose parler
une culpabilisation des victimes tu le
chercher comme quand le recteur
l'université laval avait dit aux
victimes d'agressions sexuelles y avait
juste à bord et leurs portes volets
comme non car quand c'est pas à propos
c'est violent et si dérangeant et ça
vient des femmes et des hommes ça vient
de tout le monde et c'est pour ça que
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une grande
grande grande colère parce qu'on ne les
les personnes qui ont été victimes
d'agressions en femmes ont vécu ce mon
vécu ce jugement le 7 non croyance que
alors quand j'allume peterson et benoît
dutrizac dénigrent dans ce contexte le
los ça nous fait ça nous ramène à
toujours des blessures très très intime
qui sont vraiment pas agréable donc moi
je comprends les filles d'être en colère
et que tout à fait répéter après ce
d'utiliser toutes choses qui me
dérangent et après c'est d'utiliser
le chapeau du féminisme pour pour
d'excusé ou pour danser excuses comme je
le disais je est possible que je peux
pas facile parce que je féminisme est
apte à petit justification surtout
proclamé féministe le nom mé i am a mené
c'est pas un titre que tu te donnes dans
une bâche qui est ce que tu peux te
totaux donnés comme cela m'a mené et on
l'a vu à udine avec des noms mais je
suis ministre j'ai mené j'ai été calme
on est féministe d'apple car une chose
de le dire mais c'est sais pas ce que tu
dis qui définit ton tennis mais ces
actions les actions vont pas ce sens le
jeu budget et féminisme et ou du moins
sa vision du féminisme ce que tu crois
que c'est mieux après ce haut lieu jeudi
fait il ya différentes visions qui
existent mais clairement est quelque
chose qui cloche avec celle d'août parce
que dénigrer une femme pour son physique
ou pas ce qu'a fait sur sur les réseaux
sociaux
pour moi c'est peu féminin très vite et
en même temps je comprends que des
maladresses qui sont posées puisqu'on
voit que des fois on peut commettre des
erreurs puisque c'est si si c'est facile
de déraper des fois dans le langage
commun c'est quand une discussion fermés
mais l'espace était pas la première fois
que ça arrive et son père moment donné
c'est danser dans ces lieux de paroles
faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit puis
j'ai l'impression que les médias
traditionnels de ce type le ils sont
très verticaux t c'est pas comme nous on
est dans l'horizontalité des échanges en
force quelque chose on a toujours tout
des réactions donc ça nous amène à nous
sensibiliser aux conséquences de nos
paroles alors que j'ai l'impression que
ces animateurs eux un peu inspiration
radio de québec entre guillemets lyon -
là contact direct et par exemple les
animateurs sont tous les jours à la
radio puis regarde son peu de temps ces
réseaux sociaux exactement alors moi je
dis non j'ai appris de mes erreurs l'an
passé j'en ai commis des erreurs
j'ai même déjà probablement cette chimie
quelqu'un c'est uniquement ça m'est
arrivé dans mon parcours dans de
commettre des actes et de dire des
choses qui n'avaient pas ça passe plus
jeunes chose est certaine de ce mais
j'ai appris j'ai appris que je pense que
ces gens là vont apprendre mais
peut-être pas
benoît dutrizac qui est peut-être un
petit peu ça fait longtemps qu'il est là
ça fait longtemps elle fut son cas va
apprendre de ses erreurs envie qu'eux
mais en même temps c'est très ancrée
puis à travers la voix puis tu le
mentionne bien tu nous autres mettons là
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois qu'on a dit
quelque chose sur le podcast qui la
journée où est-ce qu'on le sorte si eu
un commentaire lorsqu'on le lui aurait
fait ça c'est vrai on a l'eau n'avait
pas raison piège des images et pis car
quand tu es dans ton micro pic oeil
aucun retour c'est dedans je te mets
radio x l'attaqué avec le dock un retour
de coupe du monde vont écrire son groupe
facebook mais c'est du monde sont
d'accord avec toi qui vont nous affecter
pas de retour ce juste parlé parlé parlé
parlé puis l'objectif aussi pour ma part
les avec 3 tantôt de diviser les choses
pete est dense que l'est est médias
traditionnels versus médias sociaux ils
ont tous les médias sociaux puis moi je
me rappelle j'étais à la cub radio pour
parler je me rappelais plus avec keith
thompson jamais non plus non c'est pour
vous aimez jean arthuis je me rappelle
plus tu es c'était pour kim heger a
parlé de véganisme touquet puis la
question fait que j'arrive l'homme jeu
par le véganisme pile après ce tas ok
mais le travail est pas fait si on
divise pas fait clair il y avait la
question moi mais qu'est ce qu'on
demande qui qui vont chez mais le monde
qui achète des manteaux de fourrure de
ton chien chez kana d'agusti je dois me
lève la discussion est pas la légende
aux personnes non mais je pensais qu'on
avait une discussion où est-ce qu'on
allait parler de véganisme de comment
moi je n'entrevois pas de com mais là ça
prenait là la division va les amener la
division aussi fatiguant puis je me
rappelle l'année passée bon j'avais fait
le cover d'urbania on allait tendance
générale cité félix renault qui est un
fait que les fouets exactement pitié
j'avais remarqué que chez des gens plus
âgés l'ironie n'est n'était pas compris
thropy testé comme que si tu fais là
montrée comme soumissionnaire doit
d'abord fâché mais j'avais été invité à
une tribune médiatique assez écouté très
écoutée 1
une chaîne de radio en fait la plus
écoutée puis j'avais été assez consterné
par par la décalage entre ma génération
pis les plus âgés qui ne comprenaient
pas les codes et finalement tu es alors
que sur les réseaux sociaux ça marchait
très bien mais si j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont aussi une histoire de
génération notamment sur ma fille
elisabeth le dih yak mona par là le bien
dit d'ailleurs il ya un clash de
génération il ya deux milieux de l
espèce de réalité deux mondes qui se
parlent pas qu'ils dialoguent poche j'ai
l'impression qu'on a parlé que de saut
depuis une semaine maintenant
mais qui dit match là votre monde en
parle j'étais chez mes parents je t'ai
j'ai demandé taux élevés trio tentant de
part et d'autre ce nom c'est qui c'est
quoi tu es t à ce point le ticket comme
moi c'était omniprésence je pouvais pas
ouvrir mon ordinateur sert d'en parler
puisqu'elle n'a même pas attendu un brin
parler ça se fait que ça montre à quel
point on vit dans des dans des univers
qui sont parallèles en silo ainsi
l'autre et puis en ce moment c'est
vraiment déconnecté j'ai l'impression
que ce ça va venir à à disparaître le je
pense qu amener les réseaux sociaux où
tout va se mélanger l'association
devenir comme mm dieu où je sais poppy
une personnalité va être autant web que
telle et je pense qu'on le voit déjà
mettons this francs 10 td rosalie bon
enfant c'est une une influence eux-aussi
une personnalité radio ou télé utilisé
puis totor je pense que ça va devenir ce
n'est pour l'instant le lien espèces de
2 des clashs de génération pousse à fait
qu on se critique on 11 pointe du doigt
sans connaître le temps vraiment les
pieds c'est aussi le plus triste de
cette entrevue radio l'heure c'est que
j'te l'dis tantôt mais c'est ce que ton
propre revue tu dis que c'est vraiment
malhonnête intellectuellement de paris
12 mai tabagique quelque chose que tu
sais même pas si quad me fait un nom aux
recherches en mer
paraît-il qu'elle savait puisqu'elle a
fait un film sur la question en mettant
par de l'huile
ah ouais quand même qu est ce que je me
dis que ça vous dérange pas là vraiment
on peut prendre une pause si vous voulez
est ce que tu veux prendre compte non ce
qu'aurait c'est pour les autres ce
talent ça me dérange plus d'audace que
le film et ont cassé
c'est l'abbé trio elle avait somme toute
été épargnés du discours public au
québec le tout le monde est plus à
l'international puis le monde la connaît
devrait-on à prendre une fois dans le
cadre de l'émission influencé métier
dans le sens où le moment apparaît
beaucoup plus ils voient une réalisation
ces médias traditionnels là ça va
attaquer on peut avoir un énorme
backlash en faisant ces choses de saison
intense et punis masataka quelqu'un qui
comme kia que toute cette puissance le
derrière et elle sait calculer ya
quelque chose là que peut-être qu'ils
savaient pas qu'ils existent et l'espace
par l eau tendre et des influenceurs
c'était quand même plus les proies
faciles parce que marion pas de contenu
beaucoup de gens trouvent ce vide est
signé du fait qu'on me critique puis on
fait les docks de succès car aix ok sauf
que ça parce que surtout quand celui sur
l'islam sans ces réductions à mes tempes
et au bo doit pas le meilleur geste d
sinon la lutte il ya lieu de l'âme
excusez mon français n'est de la mare
des réseaux sociaux aussi tuer piller
pas juste bon mais la farce et que la
mare des médias traditionnels dame à
partir de là
il y en avait avant les réseaux sociaux
le dj da tv il y en a tout le temps il
ya le monde a acheté des séjours avant
qui instagram exister le vide de tout le
temps et fait partie des des
personnalités connues qui parlent de
leur vie personnelle justement pour leur
accouchement dans pile jugement mais un
peu la gueule ça satin exister parler
des relations de couple pour mousser sa
popularité dans des revues à potins ça a
tout le temps existé c'est pas un
nouveau phénomène vieux juste un nouveau
médium seppi qui elle avait tu as donné
une foule bonne entrevue avec paul
arcand je me suis entendu non c'était la
foule des bons points et 8,6 première
chose qu'ils disent est donc toi elle
habite tes influences hausse de 99 est
bon pour l'entrepreneur c'est pourquoi
tout le monde pour que les titres qu'on
lui accole l'étiquette michael c ses
influences heureuse tête en réalité
cette fille l'homme construit elle-même
une business énorme
pratiquement tout seul dans les loges de
cette poule 3 ans c'est fou c'est tu
fais le à la une et à la proue du
prodige le finalement de
l'entrepreneuriat la business pis on en
parle très peu t on pas plus du fait
caca qui appose des photos en maillot de
bain ce spi cepici comme c'était ce qui
définissait mais en réalité si fokine
entrepreneurs de deux grands succès qui
s'adresse ce qu'on critique aussi du
fait qu'un certain moment donné c'est
tout petit comme le corps parfait le
convoi a ajouté moi c'est ce que je
trouve dommage de santé chez mettons une
animatrice comme j'allais finir seul un
malaise puis un malaise très profond qui
est qui vient peut-être de blessure je
sais pas si je peux dans sa vie mais
c'est correct de dire qu'on est affectée
négativement par des images c'est elle
je ne fais une bonne publication là
dessus on peut on peut critiquer la
démarche mais maintenant parler de
violences conjugales sur un tout autre
sujet et moi comme femmes des fois je me
sens confronté je vais pas faire comme
city jeudi j'ai eu deux enfants j'ai 29
ans je viens d'accoucher je veux dire
des fois je me sens comme une grosse
marque parlant
haarde physiquement donc si correct et
défaut de sentir confrontait peut-être
par les images de corps parfait
d'elisabeth sens c'est correct d'en
parler mais il ya une façon d'exprimer
sa vérité c'est que pendant l'accusation
puis pas dans la violence comme tel mais
je pense que parce qu'elle est une femme
aussi ça ça n'aide pas sa cause de dans
ce contexte de loges durant violence est
peut être encore plus grande
mais je reviens au contexte de base
initiale qui est un code détresse et de
violences conjugales puis de le fait de
la blâmer c'est çà çà çà quand même dû
générer un grand impact négatif dans le
développement de plusieurs victimes qui
vont garder le silence parce qu'ils ont
parlé chanté par monolith ni non jeune
je pense que dans ce cas précis le jeu
thomas team et on le mettons le backlash
initiale à la sortie d'elisabeth sur la
violence conjugale mais ton est de 2
geneviève ont été largement
contrebalancé même dépassé par le
backlash à la critique mais ton qui
était de geneviève le team et ont fait
je pense qu'en bout de ligne on a
beaucoup plus parlé positivement que
négativement de sa sortie je pense qu'en
bout de ligne le fait qu'on en parle
ben sa devise est devenu une espèce de
débat de société
ça a été vraiment bénéfique plus que
négatif le finalement bowling mais plus
gros encore kaki en fait assez courant
là j'ai l'impression quand il ya des
comme des fight des batailles sur les
réseaux sociaux ya beaucoup de soleil
souvent le contrebalance y est mais moi
je me remets quand même dans la place de
sites de elizabeth qui quand même une
victime que ces géants bébé de deux mois
sa me confronte moi j'imagine que mon
cher mais ça ne mettra anglais puis je
capote je disais c'est un grand de il
d'abord comme le parent de ta fille ne
sera plus présent c'est peu importe les
raisons peu importe si je devais payer
des gens psychose je dis quelque chose
peu importe c'est vraiment je trouve
extrêmement triste pis je trouve qu'on a
on oublie de parler un peu déçu du conte
cris de la chose que hey la fillette à
tout le monde en parle dimanche qui
était debout pieds tel lot qui était et
est prête à affronter comme les caméras
petit jeu c'est pas nécessairement
évident pour cette fille là dans un
contexte où elle est encore dans la
situation de devant les tribunaux elle
est vraiment dedans d'aller devant les
caméras par une mouche vraiment j'ai
trouvé forte
puis je trouve qu'on a tendance à
déshumaniser on peut la faire beaucoup
le comme je parle pas de nous en ce
moment mais en général t on oublie la
souffrance derrière ce peu importe qui
s'exprime là dessus c'est comme j'ai
donné une entrevue
ugo monye à urbania qui était comme moi
mais c'est dur scavi geneviève m
zurich la russie connaît bien oui c'est
dur ce cas vite images il y vécut au 6e
bashing l'homme et lui aussi je remets
la situation de la fille assez fait
étranglée par son ex bonne c'est pas
drôle je dire elle aussi la souffrance
moment et et toutes les victimes
souffrent beaucoup puis moi si c'est
beaucoup de ce don parce que j'aimerais
qu'on pense à elles et eux qui vivent
cette situation le et on banalise
beaucoup en général les violences
je pourrais aller trop dans le théorique
mais en même temps je je conseille cet
ouvrage là qui comptent qui
s'intéressent à la question patrick remy
taux qui psychologue qui écrit le
science des mortes puis elle s'est
intéressée à commandant la société ont
banalisé les violences faites les
violences faites aux femmes dans son col
de particuliers une particulière faite
aux fables cas s'intéressait le sujet de
sa thèse et finalement tu es à l'éclat
mine vraiment toutes les rhétoriques de
banalisation des violences comme ce
qu'on a entendu avec peterson et
dutrizac et ici fascinant parce que
quand porte oreilles on se rend compte
que c'est partout dans discours ambiant
puis aussi dans nos discussions dans la
quotidienneté de cesser c'est un vrai
enjeu un vrai problème
et sam je pense que c'est très très
instructive ce qui se passe là dessus
entre commence à me des bombes que c'est
encore tellement d'actualité mais que le
cancer est pas parce que les nouvelles
générations semble être
réveillé par payer phi phi le mois ça
m'épate leur ressenti des gens comment
s'est exprimé en ce moment tu essaies
foule comme la solidarité quand même
c'est très chaud ce bien en fait je
trouve ça vraiment positif du sommet
clerc marty
elle n'avait pas envie non c'est pas
envie de passer à travers ce prix puis
je suis petit et puis geneviève
pietersen je pense que c'est qu'elle
avait envie de vivre ce que je pense que
ça pourra revenir dans le temps afin de
réguler ces s'allierait pas là parce que
je pense que c'est finalement en bout de
ligne la société peut-être et gagnante
parce qu'on une conversation autour de
ce métier c'est celui-là beta2
excessivement difficile puis désagréable
à vivre vraiment toute la situation mais
je pense qu'on en revient l'idée que ces
gens l'ont et micro pics sont rarement
confronté parce que aussi peut-être que
brad ou c'est pas si populaire que ce
jeu c'est poste une nouvelle radio je
connais pas les côtes d'écouté non plus
vite mais peut-être aussi que les
affaires comme ceux où au sourire qu'ils
sont 10 puis qui ont juste pas ses
fruits parce que c'était pas le trio les
affaires comme ça puisse le sais je sais
qui tu viens de taille était la personne
qu'il fallait politique sont un sujet
qu'il fallait papier mais sait aussi que
ça s'est retrouvé sur lcn moitié à la
base lcn c'est quand même bon c'est
quand même écouté que je dirais tu es
sur les ondes publiques club d'où
l'information sans réseau d'information
je me suis à l'intervention à quel point
tous et informatif textile extimité
c'est vrai ça fait vraiment bizarre tout
ça tout ça était bizarre mais vraiment
donc moi puis et comment accueillir
finalement les victimes de violence dans
ce contexte-là moi je pense que c'est
important de rappeler un peu comment
agit justement c'est tellement ceux ci
on a l'exemple de comment ne pas agir
quand une victime vient nous voir pour
une jauge été victimes de
c'est à dire remettre en question pour
toutes sortes de raisons sa sexualité
sont physiques et cetera toutes les
facteurs externes qui n'ont aucun
rapport
quant aux victimes viennent voir la
première chose à faire c'est de
l'écouter d'être dans le fait qu'à
roulante souffrant qui est spécialisé
dans les questions de violences
sexuelles étaient venus à mon podcast
elle pas pierre raconter un peu comment
agir ptc social il coûte c'est le
remercie que la victime d'avoir d'avoir
partagé son expérience dans ce contexte
là c'est très difficile de parler de
transmettre que je dirais donc de
remercier de considérer et de donner de
l'aide comme on peut mais mais c'est
tellement pas de juger c'est pas à nous
de juger dans ces circonstances le puits
si vous saviez à quel point ça pourra
être banalisée des situations de
violence conjugale et moi ce que je
trouve aussi dommage c'est que c'est ça
nous prend toujours le gros coup de
poing sa gueule pour qu'on réagit cité
mais la violence conjugale
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
quand j'ai j'ai signé une lettre j'ai en
fait j'ai adhéré à une lettre signée par
les péripatéticiennes qui a été publié
sur le devoir au journal le devoir et il
parle du concept de continuum c'est à
dire de dire que la violence conjugale
cesser tout un et les violences comme
tel faites aux femmes c'est un continuum
de violence et à l'extrémité on ne le
meurtre on ne les actes de violence plus
visible physique coups de poing sur la
gueule et ses termes et à travers sauter
pour y arriver ça prend la violence
psychologique il ya plein de sortes de
violence et tout c'est un grand
phénomène et c'est pas à banaliser le
début de cette violence là ça commence
par de la mesquinerie ça commence par
des petits gestes et c est donc pour moi
ce que je trouve dommage c'est de dire
ben ça nous prend finalement le grand
spectacle de l'étranglement pour réagir
mais tin nous si on était moins autour
de nous de cas de violence qui à plus
petite échelle
c'est important de réagir avant que ça
aille le est ce que j'ai trouvé aussi
hypocrite quelque part si tu sais mes
dialogues qui position médiane mais en
général on est tellement on crie au
scandale quand une femme meurt sous les
coups de son mari bouton a eu plusieurs
cas où cela les derniers mois le
confinement a pas aidés à la santé
mentale de tous mais s'il peut agir le
cas isabelle rioux a su être anglais
sait que c'est dangereux ça
peut mener à la mort malheureusement
c'est sur la situation et je veux pas
avoir l'air alarmiste mais il faut
réagir
il faut qu'on dise non à ça donc voilà
je croise en plus hypocrite de la part
de ce média l'acquis qui crient au
scandale quand quelqu'un m'a mail et
donc une situation qui qui qui qui
ajoute à l'espèce de l'espèce de vertige
des derniers mois m c'est de sentir que
la santé mentale de tous est de plus en
plus affecté de sentir que les
fragilités des gens sont exposés
puis que moi c'est le feeling que moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on en n'étant pas
en train de de manquer de souffle dans
cette dans toute l' les derniers mois
t-il le début du confinement à petit
j'ai l'impression qu'on commence à
manquer de souffle un peu que les
mouvements qu'on commence à du moins est
arrivé au bout de ce qu'on a le titre
des ressources qu'on a
j'aimerais sur son programme je veux
dire la santé mentale puis j'ai fait un
petit mot sur instagram pour dire est ce
que monsieur le premier ministre
pourrait donner plus d'argent aux
groupes de femmes battues puis aux
maisons d'hébergement métier ça équivaut
aussi pour la santé mentale jeu et oui
on est à bout de souffle je crois tous
et toutes le par rapport à ça est
rizzoli pouvoir déjà c'est pas bon pour
la santé mentale pas faire de sport
c'est pas bon pour la santé mentale et
si pas pour rien que l'augmentation
flagrante 10 appels à l'aide sur la
police de québec
je pense les pompiers qui ont dit que 30
% d'augmentation d'appels pour violences
conjugales il vraiment le comme une
augmentation des violences en général
pis c'est pas juste domestique c'est
dans le vus lancé dans l'espace public
on en parlait je veux dire les antilles
marquis qui arrive avec digonnet aux
états unis c'est une montée des
violences c'est je pense que c'est
l'effet d'isolement l'effet des ce
l'effet du contexte aussi en bien avancé
il y avait la crise climatique aussi
qu'ils étaient très anxieux pense qu'ils
manquent de ressources je devrais aller
voir un psychologue ça coûte cher mais
c'est super impressionnant qui arrivent
des sociale la précarité monétaire en ce
moment les quelques convives tous les
deux phares look et c'est là qu'est
l'opc ok qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est là
il ya des business qui ont pris nous on
est chanceux on ne sut diot qui
fonctionne encore mais quand tu ajoutes
se situe depuis que leur sort était
scellé t'endormir pis tu te fais juste
penser à tout ce que le lendemain en
fait il pas de lever de soleil à
l'horizon le dans un futur rapproché
fait que c'est sacré encore plus le
vertige que je parlais tantôt en fait
j'ai l'impression
moi je pense qu'on réalisait pas au
début de l'été avec le pc eu c'est vrai
que c'est un impact très positif
finalement on est très très chanceux
d'être nonchalant deux femmes
ce contexte euler
mais manquer d'argent en vie puis pas
savoir comment payer son loyer la
pauvreté c'est quand même loin du stress
les plus grands qui peuvent vivre de ne
pas savoir comment tu vas de nourrir ta
femme et puis on vit un contexte
économique
historiquement vraiment marquant négatif
c'est fou ce qui se passe finalement
mais je pense qu'on était un peu dans
notre bulle au début du confinement avec
la pcu les taux qui arrivait du monde
qui était connue sur le pc c'est une
faute parce que c'était quand même 10
août pour des jaquettes restait quand
même
mais lol pcu qui disparaît l'automne qui
arrive aussi le manque de liberté c'est
toutes sortes de facteurs qui doit bien
voilà c'est ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
dur mais c'est bien dans la dépression
mais c'est ce type qui justement c'est
ce moment là où est ce que on recevait
la pcu pitt et jeudi en début de
podcasts
je télécharge chance à la paix c'est une
tige mettait dans le fond on emprunte un
peu longue piste il faut que le
gouvernement contribue pitié pipi
évidemment sauf que faut s'attendre
collectivement on va payer cette dette
le long temps de répit ça va prendre des
années des décennies world xi à vivre
les conséquences de cette crise
je souhaite c'est quand même tout les
restaurateurs les entrepreneurs vous
êtes vous cette chance et probablement
dans ce contexte là mais ça doit être
quelque chose
vraiment un restaurant pizza bombe hype
c'est fini c'est terminé je trouvais
qu'on était comme vraiment on était dans
une belle envolée économique en fait là
on était dans une prospérité certaine
avant confinement il semble que le
canada allait assez bien il entreprendra
bon ça allait bien savourer c'est fou ce
qui s'est passé finalement c'est
terrible c'est jamais j'aurais pu croire
ou pensé vivre ceux ci on parlait
souvent de virus pandémie mais testé
comme pas concrets comme les strass mais
je pensais que j'allais moi non mouche
pas je pensais pas que ce n'est pas dans
mon enfance je suis pas je pensais pas
que le confinement c'était quelque chose
qui était dans l'univers du possible
avant que ça arrive
les personnes qui dit haïtienne pandémie
mondiale ça se peut qu'on se confirme à
petit on avait pu tout faire mon épaule
droite vraiment sortir de vos demandes
typique les premières fois car par les
chaluts ben voyons donc c'est impossible
c'est pis je pense qu'on a tous une
forte de banalisation du coc vide
mettons en février dernier à tampa bay
au début d'année comprennent le sérieux
doutes subsistaient comme voyons les
médias exagèrent petite nana puisqu'elle
qui n'ont cessé vrai si c'est vrai c'est
qu'on se confirme ça dure longtemps
qui sait parler d'opération il y aura
peut-être mon appareil avait elle est
abordée lundi des restaurateurs qui
perdent 95 % de leur revenu jour
l'entente est plutôt peut pas espérer
payer son loyer encore bien longtemps
c'est excessivement difficile tellement
de gens qui perdent leur emploi déjà
payant quand même en hôtellerie c'est
pas évident à la musique mais pas je
souhaitais mois
écoute cancer à l'hôpital puis j'ai
accouché dans les circonstances que
vinista témoin j'avais jeté dans le
triage pij de dilater à 4 pour les
petits détails pour ceux qui savent tout
cela veut dire pour ceux qui veut sa
revanche jeté dans une salle de triage
pc si j'attendais ils voulaient me
renvoyer chez nous chez comme non je
veux à coucher 7000 et ses mots dans le
grillage puis autres bref c'est arrivé
pendant mes abonnés de moi y avait s'il
y avait un couple anti mars
2 qu'est qui était un petit peu en rage
et on va la fermer l'école normale
ils voulaient pas se faire tester pour
l'aco vide qui est agressif
puis vous les peuples la fillette avait
accouché c'est moi j'étais à côté de
tubes j'étais comme étant qu'elles m'ont
dziwisz et puis là j'ai pensé à comme
les artisans la santé le pauvre et on en
a beaucoup parlé au printemps mars on
était comme les infirmières lâchez pas
les médecins lâchez pas les préposés
n'en sait pas mais lâchez pas pour vrai
sérieusement moi quand ils m'ont
transféré dans la zone rouge
depuis que j'ai été enfermé dans ma
petite pièce le g bad trip et je voulais
10 mai pensez à ces gens là qui doivent
gérer c'est une zone de guerre là vous
n'avez pas idée à quel point c'est
traumatisant cellule les gens sont
stressés on a peur on veut petit c'est
tout le monde est tributaire et on est
tous responsables on veut pas ramené le
virus à maison contamine une famille que
notre enfant qu'on soigne avec notre
enfant qui à la garderie puis il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de conséquences
surya ce même témoin d'avoir été
diagnostiquée il a fallu que j'appelle
des gens qui ont perdu genre 14 ans d'un
travail c'est beaucoup c'est si beaucoup
d'impact qu'on pense pas puis cette zone
de garda dans les hôpitaux en ce moment
je dirais c'est l'horreur pour eux c'est
très très très difficile nous on est
dans notre bulle puis oui on a été
violée par un but
non mais eux voir vraiment comme c'est
très déprimant pis dame dans mon 48
heures enfermé que j'étais comme est-ce
que je vais contaminé ma fille j'ai
toute la baisse d'énergie puis on
appelle ça aussi l'espèce de baisse
hormonale tout comme quand même un petit
post partum de 48 heures moi je les vis
seul dans ma chambre puis c'était
vraiment bizarre c'est vraiment comme
j'aurais pu faire une psychose pigeonne
sincèrement c'était alien mais toi
facteurs d'accoucher ouais tu étais où
matt hackett a vu la gravité des
symptômes n'ont jamais eu de symptômes
ok bim et puis le petit fille elle
sortit touama lavabo à laver pop se
lasser comme ben particulier parce qu'il
n'avait pas c'est moi j'étais là premier
code les pages le de l'hôpital qui était
comme on sait pas comment gérer ce petit
jeu au début de la deuxième vague mais
j'ai pensé à ces gens qui vont mourir
dans ce contexte de love is all in
on en a parlé mais j'aimerais redire
pour avoir été isolé en accouchant c'est
comme donner la vie c'est comme une
grosse étape mais aussi mouret qui est
une grande étape de la vie puis j'ai
pensé à ceux et andré ducharme à fait
l'esprit parle à tout le monde en parle
en scène r&b oïli a parlé de son parc
immoral urgence puisqu'elle n'a jamais
pu y el al et le blanc qui mourir dans
ce contexte de l'homme je vous dirai ce
c'est ici effroyable ça doit et
effroyable je peux pas concevoir et
écoles ok si le dernier moment de ma vie
je me sens pas bien comment tu comme
maicon
c'est vraiment triste mon grand père il
y avait un frère restant froides en font
toute la famille était évidemment ses
parents sont décédés tous ses frères et
soeurs puis le son frère pendant la
cavité mon grand-père ya 85 1 pendant
que vides
il appelait le dit pierre je t'appelle
pour te dire adieu parce que ils
venaient demander l'aide médicale à
mourir puis des à cause de la crevaison
pour au poste fait que c'est son dernier
frère et la belle lui dit je t'appelle
pour te dire adieu le monde grand paris
chez eux puis son dernier frère puis ok
football c'est comme si tu es resident
evil mon grand père est il reste des
années encore le type
il est encore super en forme petit et je
touche du bois j'espère vraiment qu'ils
vont voir et revoir dès noël puis de
noël avec lui il estimé
mais quand même de dire la seule paire
la personne qui était le plus longtemps
à vis encore vivante
tu peux même pas la halle et la prend
dans ses bras
sinon on comprenait pas ce qu'ils voient
la mort arriver on le sait qu'ils y at
il pas un accident ce procès c'est quand
qu'il lui pisser la chapelle pour te
dire bête c'est vraiment vraiment très
petit morceau sale à frapper maintenant
ce qu'ils mangent que de couper mois se
mettant cette histoire le même si je
t'ai je suis ultra pro pour les mesures
sanitaires pile
le confinement de vraiment moi je plonge
dans le cadre exagérons un peu puis
règles on sera apprêté pour trouver des
gens le tir puis puis cette histoire là
tout le monde disait l'acavite ça nous
affecte pas pita personnes proches de
toi puis personne dans cette jungle et
et mordre la queue vite mais mais cela
que vides qui crée cette espèce de
distance le où est ce que quelqu'un de
85 ans peut même pas risquer de sortir
de chez eux pour aller dire adieu à son
frère
c'est là qu'habite qui fait ce risque
lui attire quand le monde passait juste
sur pour les vielles personnes
c'est peut-être juste pour les vieilles
personnes mais 4 85 ans piquionne te
passer toute ta vie ton frère que t'aime
beaucoup tu peux pas le voir
tu as ça tue moins de valeur que
quelqu'un en vain tenté de dire oui à
qui est ici ça fait que juste les
vieilles personnes mais c'est des
personnes aussi stupide mal qui sont des
piliers dans notre société c'est du
monde qui ont qui ont à raconter des
choses c'est du monde kick qui ont vécu
qui ont plus d'expérience que tout le
monde pitié je vous dérouiller c c'est
plate ces gens là vont mourir
naturellement mais pas là pas de suite
pas comme ceux c'est le doigt là la
dignité la dignité c'est le droit à
mourir justement puis me semble conçu un
truc de justice générationnel aussi
qu'ils ont droit à une marque vraiment
puis bienveillante en quelque part à
mourir étouffés dans une salle de la
norme est un cauchemar ce que tu dis
finalement c'est qu'on humanis est
d'humaniser ces histoires là qui nous
sommes tellement loin puis c'est comme
les cas de violence qu'on ne revient
qu'en banalise une situation c'est qu'on
n'a pas vécu tant pis si gai quand c'est
le vent les chefs à chaque fois que d'un
point de presse du premier ministre à
1300 nouveaux corps 25 mhz en plus
acquis 25 mans ch et celle des ça votre
un shift à touche-pipi mais une histoire
cette chance
une histoire ça touche pipi pas je
souhaitais y ait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de d'opérations qui sont mises
en attente des cancers qui sont opposés
à une éthique et c'est peut-être le
cancer de ta mère qu'un cancer du sein
si tu le sais pas en ce moment à vos pas
l'hôpital juste ma cause oui on va
passer par diagnostic et puis y'a pas de
suivi bhl c'est compliqué puis beaucoup
de problèmes la santé aussi qu'ils vont
générer puis finalement il ya plein de
conséquences sur nos vies qu'on voit
peut-être pas maintenant moi ça a été la
couche mais finalement j'étais aussi
dans le sur ce côté hugh lula mais quand
j'ai fait
ok c'est ça que ça veut dire puis à
diagnostiquer et pis aussi comme
l'express autour de soi comme les gens
qui ont acheté chez dû côtoyer jolie
touche je les transmets ma grand mère
c'est comme exponentielle donc non même
pas moi je suis d'accord avec toi qui
était des fois il faut faire faire
preuve de jugement puis d'abord un peu
de souplesse parce qu'on cherche à faire
mieux tous ensemble quand même pis pour
la question de santé mentale moi de voir
des gens se contente de vous voir tous
sa tête bien c'est l'une des rares
rencontres que j'aurais eu cette eau
donne tes c'est quand même fou par aimer
mais c'est tellement il ya tellement de
variables dans l'équation tri comment
qu'on gère une pandémie mondiale
il est tellement une infinité de
variables qui le casse tête que c'est de
peser les pour et les contre et qu'ici
on confine plus les pour ce sommet les
concessions dans l'olympic
je voudrais pas être celui qui le raphia
rodage
je voudrais pas te rassure 2 je voudrais
pas de premier ministre et bbm déchu du
terme des fieux exact parce qu'ils en
font la queue vide
peu importe comment tangente plage dorée
mieux ou pire mais ça va de la varde il
ya des gens qui vont écoper pipi c'est
ça mais si tu vois l'histoire ton
histoire de dettes au grand pape son
frère ses soucis c'est une dérive
possible de gestion de tous tant qu'à
moi c'est pas parce que si c'est
forcément tu sais déjà ce type ce que je
comprends pourquoi il ya des règlements
pour les applique
mais après ce tir la mort s'ils ont
encore une chose d'un peu sacré pire
où est ce que la dignité de ses pires
qu'il rituel quand même à bertrand sept
ans
le point que je voulais faire accès
d'histoire le point que ma qui
m'apparaît à moi c'est que ses yeux il
ya eu beaucoup de cocon d'éclosion
innocent il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
faisait des parts est juste allant loin
encore il ya un partage 1-1 outaouais de
65 personnes dans un dans une maison
louée et et qui a été démantelé le monde
au karaoké toutes ces affaires le type
qui ont contribué parce que ça demandera
un couple ça n'en prend pas de dix mille
cent après le couple de petit cocon de
mind après ceux ci reparti et puis il ya
eu beaucoup de personnes qui sans son
corps ait eu beaucoup de personnes qui
ont fait 0 attention mais je fais
attention je peux la personne qui qui
qui est maniaque halle puis pitié j'ai
l'impression que si on avait
collectivement fait un petit coup de
plus durant l'été pour éviter que ça
reparte de même possiblement que mon
grand père serait allé voir son frère
surtout lequel je vais aller parce que
mon gras pas si ils sont appelés c'est
lui il voulait pas plus il ya les autres
- facetime pour se voir sur macbook mais
l'effort dé guerre il n'y a pas tenu ses
souliers pas d'un du stationnement n'ont
pas dû non plus en ce sens que nous
mêmes se regarde dans un miroir là par
rapport à ça cc c'est là que c'est là
qu'ils aiment manger sacre de partir je
voudrais y en a qui l'on voyage bien
d'autres miss testé cet été c'était
c'était comme le plus le yoyo la kfw
décaissement pu le situer qu'à qu'on a
senti ça partait puis on en avait parlé
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait qu'une
deuxième vague qui va sans mener à peu
près l'automne ont tout le monde est au
courant
tout le monde en parle depuis que ça
commencer plus qu'un salon commencé à
faire ça il ya encore du monde qui est
qui étaient ouverts le confinement en
fait moi je moi je
j'ai fini je reconfirme papy le savent
que ça fait maintenant il ya aussi
peut-être est-ce que je t'ai interrompue
mais c'est juste et il ya les critiques
des démesures des collègues de rester un
minimum jeudi
critique le thé en voir les décisions
qui se prennent pour dire ce que toute
une réflexion après se sait les discours
ces paroles entendues récemment disco
déjà om et y mettons le nombre de cas en
ce moment ne justifie pas les coups
à quel point les maisons sont extrêmes
de prendre les noms des couilles it
élevé et deuxièmement la première chose
oui si tu as entre guillemets decaux ou
de décès que c'est parce que des mesures
puis on n'a pas les chiffes de si on
n'avait pas l'émission faisait rien fait
si comme c'est comme de dire il ya
beaucoup de courses et de prouver que
les mesures sont efficaces ces sacs sont
fixés comme un non sens et je pense
qu'il est aussi des comme des petites
erreurs en termes de communication
gouvernement au début c'était bien parti
mais un moment donné c'était plus
logique puis je pense que les gens sont
quand même pas du puy ont besoin de
cohérence il lui manquait de cohérence
tic pourquoi pourquoi fermer les cinémas
pourquoi fermer les secteurs culturels
d'abord borsus des jeux ça a été comme
moi j'écris ce qui est moins promis de
dire ça faisait pas pour respecter les
mesures de santé publique parce qu'ils
savent que ce que nous moi ce que
j'entends de se figer des primaires
critiquées parce que le désert personne
qui peut me convaincre qu'il ya plus de
chances d'attraper la queue vite dans un
top 10 dans ces masques et god gmt mais
il semaine d'après à former les jeunes
meetic en parle elle de deux mauvais pas
des mauvais coups le met de mauvaise
gestion puis de dérapage tu parles de
ton grand père métier comme moi
maintenant dans chaque chambre d'hôpital
une vraiment comme quelque chose qui
était pas logique
il y avait la machine arrière la
conversion air qui pourrait amener mon
vraiment alliés ni le stampede comme une
goutte d'eau le supplice de la courbe et
elles sont quittés honnêtement il ya eu
des intervenants à la fin de mon séjour
qui était comme qui sont arrivés puis t
d un ferme en paie les frais ça n'a pas
de bon sens je dois couper se sont
immédiatement puis a présenté comme un
médecin qui arrive puisqu'il me donne
mon congé d'hôpital moi j'avais comme en
fait j'étais plus capable j'avais fermé
là
la chine qui était que ben en fait avait
même pas réagi au fait qu'il avait même
plus la machine puis si comme tu sais à
quel point ça ça me détruit puis mon
enfant imminence de son lit à 70
décibels il ya de l'impact qu'il peut
avoir un impact néfaste sur louis de mon
enfant petit c'est juste comme
l'incohérence de concret de la chose
puis après ils me renvoient deux
semaines la maison ils font jamais comme
le suivi de mise admis en fait parce
qu'ils n'ont jamais fait de suivi la
santé publique on peut faire le suivi de
mai 2001 est venu chez moi j'agis pas
contacté tout petit j'aurais pu ne pas
contacter tout le monde que j'ai croisés
qu'est ce qui vous dit que j'ai croisés
parce que c'est des petits éléments
comme ça c'est pas de la faute aux gens
tout le monde et tout le monde est
vraiment joué que des roms mais je
trouvais que ça faisait pas de sens
restée pauvre c'était parce que je pense
que tout le monde apprend sur le seul
exemple quand un prénom exact que tu
apprends sultan on a parlé je pense avec
un clavier ou est ce qu'on disait de ces
dans le fond la science et date avance
de 2 pendant que de tenter de marquer
lorsque l'on y assistent on voit ce we
pied ça risque de revenir ton dit
souvent mais ça risque de revenir pas
nécessairement avec la cabine mais avec
d'autres on limite les pis bon quand
j'écoutais johanne rouleau de l'ancienne
présidente de médecins sans frontières
qui a parlé de sa gestion des crises de
les voleurs en afrique on s'entend qu'on
n'a pas eu les boeufs là je veux dire
qu'ils étaient qui était quand même
spectaculaire où la tuberculose dans les
années 40 le au québec c'était grave
l'on n'en mourrai vraiment le pij moi
j'ai une grande tente qui est morte à 14
ans la tuberculose sais pas si c'est pas
de nouveaux puits savoir revenir pis ça
va être probablement encore plus qui
leur en guillemin parce que le oui
effectivement c'est peut-être une grippe
c'est des problèmes respiratoires
ça touche pas tout le monde mais quand
ça va toucher avec des plaies pis que tu
vas mourir c'est ça c'est pour ça aussi
donc j'ai hâte de voir que mon maximum
ma grand mère biologique que j'ai peu
connus piqué qui décidez quand ma mère
avait 3 1 et de la polio c'est que la
fameuse palier qui borde la polio
aujourd'hui triple aux jo je voyais
un mime le des sciences et le genre god
polio nos tanks sayen c'était parce que
j'en ai merci parce que on c'est
d'actionner puis on a trouvé un remède
qui l'ont le plus fin que j'ai discuté
avec les anti pacs il ya des sorties on
en parle souvent des draps est important
de s'exposer à toutes les opinions puis
bien sûr toute opinion j'ai pas vraiment
je suis assez conscients qu'ils
reportent communication possibles
activement c'est comme dom tom en amont
processus des fois des documentaires sur
différents projets comme est ce que j'ai
envie d'interviewer un radicaliser non
parce que il est encore c'est une
personne radicaliser qui dans son
idéologie
qu'est ce qu'elle va nous apporter
vraiment et apport à part répété son
idéologie et manipuler un peu
l'information pour que ça passe bien
j'aime mieux parler à des gens qui se
sont des radicalités ou qui sont plus
par là - dans les extrêmes mais
sincèrement je me fie à la science je
crois qu'en ce sens que si on était en
effet un local c'est maintenant les
sorties les frasques de ses lauriers
maintenant ouais mon frère que cet été
la voix de podcasts par un cheval arabe
comme ne s'était pas propagée sur pc
même si comprendre cette personne le
sadisme dessus données l'expo jouer à
des idées qui devraient au point d'avoir
certains des baux avec quelqu'un qui qui
représentent une infime inactifs thomas
de la pensée pie x ont besoin
d'information et je dirais peau et pour
former l'opinion d'une personne non
expertes qui s'informent sur youtube
puis sur des blogs par 3 offrant la même
valeur qu'un consensus de gens qui font
des post doc dans 90 mais c'est ce que
je trouve un peu chiant dans cette ère
de l'opinion le sait que finalement tout
le monde devient expérience deux autres
de veepee tout le monde te donne des
leçons puis votre faim si quand même
dommage pour la pensée on n'aime pas les
intellectuels on n'aime pas les entendre
on aimerait tant les scientifiques c'est
ce que ça donne comme ceux ci étaient en
randonnée
il est des revues de littérature qui se
font il ya des gens qui sont des vrais
des vrais cheminement intellectuel ça
serait le fun qu'on les entende plus
plutôt qu'on parle de jardinage de
telles vedettes et qui tira là-dessus
j'adore ans par la perspective de marie
france bazzo que l'état des médias aussi
et pas très bon je fais en ce moment
pour donner la voix ou vraie réflexion
c'est pour ça j'ai l'impression aussi
que les podcasts vont prendre de
l'ampleur mes meilleurs mais assorti sic
on peut aussi dire tout et n'importe
blues sur les toits de gaspé si c'est
pour sauver les personnes qui quittent
cheikh new team et ont semé un devoir
une pression d'essayer d'être le plus
factuel possible
est ce qu'on nous a dit des choses qui
étaient sur le quitter et quittez pas
vrai sans savoir c'est sûr on le fait
tous ses pieds personnes qui factcheck
en arrière de ce qu'ils se dotent on
fait attention mettez quelqu'un on
pourrait repartir podcasts et promouvoir
des idées conspirationnistes personnes
hickson a déjà refusé des pêcheries vous
reviendrez poche de même si je parlais
de saadoun mort d'onde mais je tenais
beaucoup de conférences avant avant la
cabine mais il ya quelques années puis
sont là et les questions d'image
corporelle et toupie des faux chèques
sommes mal à l'aise parce que les gens
écoutaient trop ce que je dis c'est
comme avec besoin de se faire dire le
chemin vers le bien-être et l'équilibré
puis des fois t'es comme plus chier à
l'aise devant la scène puisque je
parlais avec assurance j'avais
l'impression que c'est parce qu'à
l'agglo
dans le sol et non mais j'ai une
anecdote à ce sujet domine une fois une
conférence en beauté comme des madame
d'un groupe de femmes meetic hommes plus
âgés genre 60 65 ans mais ces défis
ministre est un peu plus à droite qui
voit de la motion puis il me regarde ses
pieds carrés si vous voulez passer cela
pour rien avec une pièce si je voulais
être convaincu pin up
ça y est je me suis vu paris comme
qu'est ce qui se passe ça c'est très
bizarre puis je me suis dit bon on va va
faire tout d'abord qui jeune fille va
étudier en plus il ya plutôt que de
parler comme si tu savais tout l'été
jusqu'à 12 ans alors tais toi vieux
métiers même aujourd'hui je me sens très
mal non il ya quelque chose j'ai eu un
cours sur la théorie des genres
littéraires à l'université puis on
parlait des instances de légitimation de
commencer important dans la société
d'avoir des instances de légitimation
parce que là c'était plus mettons 6 et u
publier un livre dans stato publie son
livre dans ton seul tu l'ex pdis a le
moins de valeur que si tu est publié
chez gallimard mettons parce que c'est
une instance de lille utilisation puis
ce à mon avis c'est une des choses qui
nous reste pour essayer de séparer les
informations mettant un article que tu
vaux lire dans le devon le devoir c'est
une instance de la victimisation plus
que un blog la gelée dire la clique du
plateau le mais comme plus que n'importe
quel blog est toujours premier sur
facebook
pis ça je pense que c'est important de
remettre en perspective c'est parce que
parce que c'est pas vrai que toutes les
opinions sont égaux c'est juste pas vrai
c'est ton opinion que c'est le minois
mais peut-être le mieux plus informés
que le sien le type qui est d'avoir des
instances de légitimisation j'en reviens
sur ce que je trouve que c'est vraiment
une bonne façon de le voir je pense
qu'il faut établir ce
établir tout perdre ce qui fait la
hiérarchie a pris hier archi dation
pardon de ceux là c'est une question
européenne des erreurs quand même mais
j'ai malgré tout l'impression qu'il faut
accorder plus d'importance à certaines
sources d'information qu'à d'autres
puis attelage faut essayer dans nos
propres choses de devenir une instance
de l'inondation par la qualité de ce que
tu produis de ce que de faire le média
indépendant accord c'est ce qu'un devoir
mater comme c'est drôle parce que même
dans le film dans le monde universitaire
ça se produit t on à lire les revues lit
en fait oui les revues qui sont
scientifiques qui sont considérés et
revues par les pairs et ça c'est des
revues qui sont légitimes tenais thuau
sa légitimité dans l'espace public puis
on reconnaisse l'ascension puis la
nécessité de se mais il ya de plus en
plus un phénomène de revues
effectivement un peu obscur qui ne sont
pas revues parlées pas dans le temps des
scientifiques qui qui se font entendre
et voir et ça je pense que ça contribue
aussi dans un monde scientifique l'homme
sait si le rendu du tout et n'importe
quoi mais il est important de garder son
tapis moi ça me fait un peu rire aussi
des en tout cas j'ai comme une amie qui
est maintenant chrome 15 aux devoirs
picchi professeur qui est devenu
professeur puis je les reçois mon
podcast pis je des sites une autorité en
la matière de relations internationales
c'est quelqu'un qui est en train de
faire sa place dans le monde
universitaire piquer des idées et qui
travaille fort pierre dr up par un poste
de l'europe et qui a fini première à
dante une autre conquête d'un gros c'est
une grosse bourse postdoctorale la plus
grosse au canada en fête bilic cool qui
viennent commenter son article sous
l'article dessous la publication du
devoir méditer ils ont aimé c'est qui
est la femme qui parle de toupie je suis
juste années comme verbe et la section
commentaires sérieusement cette femme là
beaucoup plus de légitimité que toute
l'étape on l'est qui viennent puisque à
aider les commentaires moi j'ai j'ai de
moins en moins de misère avec cette idée
le de fer qui checke le seul on sait que
ça va amener plein de commentaires qu'on
veut même pas lire parce qu'on sait que
sont déjà au crédit de fêtes 2,2
on peut certains crieront à la censure
mais en même temps je pense que censurer
certaines opinions
quand tu est une instance de lille
utilisation ces pauvres mais l'ascenseur
au nom de quoi je dire là on parle de
ton territoire on parle de teruel
facebook d'une propriété privée mais ça
tu appartiens selon les codes du réseau
jeudi rompu on peut aussi en revenir la
censure la liberté d'expression oui mais
au canada
elle est encadrée on a une charte
canadienne des droits et libertés on
n'est pas dû aux états unis où c'est le
deuxième amendement à la constitution
qui est donc qui prime sur tout on s'est
dit que s'il y avait des propos haineux
ce y avait des propos d'harcèlement et
cetera si des propos discriminatoires
été menée dans l'espace public on avait
le droit de se questionner à savoir ce
propos la était légitime ou pas donc les
gens qui sont pour la liberté
d'expression par dessus tout s'il vous
plaît et lyon en considération ce vivre
ensemble selon ben ça va donner une
société pollué par partout et n'importe
quoi puis on voit ce que ça donne aux
états unis je dire à cette liberté
d'expression à tout prix amène des
dérapages sérieuses et pas là le seul et
unique élément l'éducation le système
d'éducation aux états unis est lacunaire
problématique de l'accès à l'éducation
une problématique dont quand que bref
moi ça me tape un peu aussi sur les nas
cet argumentaire là qui revient tout le
temps
mettez la section commentaire d'un art
et sous des articles ce phénomène
relativement nouveau dans ce sens car
j'ai toujours nagé vous il ya une
section qu'il faudrait pas tout
expliquer par le monde autour de toi je
trouve que tu aimais tant s'émousser
quand il le faut je vois l'article passé
je tombe je suis même pas vraiment c'est
comme si on avait une valeur supérieure
à tout commentaire gabriel tycoon
chamakh hommes sur l'article en tant que
tel kelakh puce il vient juste exister
comme sur puis tu anticipes de l'est ou
non depuis mai mais je veux venir sur le
sentiment que ta vie tu te sens pas
intéressant qu'en dessous de donner des
conférences et de tables l'impression
d'avoir une espèce de deux heures
au final j'ai jamais parlé des tubes non
mais c'est drôle parce que tu aimais
tant c'est toi tu viens mal à l'aise
avec ce mais quelqu'un qui qui qui fait
une conférence le monde
mathieu le monde boivent les paroles ça
bref en dix ans ne touche d exemple
d'amour à personne mais si tu vois moi
je trouve que on donne vraiment trop
d'importance à l'opinion des vedettes
intellec c'est une vedette se prononce
sur une question de politique ou une
question souvent de santé ou de
l'hébergement les humoristes que les
humoristes les beats et ses soutiens ben
si tu veux parler quelque chose
d'hamilton humeur et sa tête son
émission de radio en télé cf
l'autre couple laurent turcot qui
parlait de la république de l'humour au
québec
est ce parce que c'est s'attirer sujet
tabou par contre parce que si tu abordes
tu mens risques pouvant aller sur des
plateaux de télé pour deux matchs il a
parlé de politique tout un tas
humoristes se parler des 6e mais c'est
ça c'est rendu certains humoristes dont
1 kg nommément les missions qu'on aime
notre peau meetic il faudrait des
émissions puis qui donne déjà des
conseils sans compter sur pas grand
chose je sais c'est pas un expert en
domaine si je comprends pas pourquoi on
accorde autant d'importance à à la
pensée justement de la vie d'athlète
épices commission de georges saint
geours de culte de la personnalité de
laver des tpi c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya
aussi des gens qui drive seulement deux
ans à l'influencé ou pouvoir ben ça
dérape a certainement le tpiy
puis le savons ça peut aller jusqu'à
automatisé de dénonciation il ya plein
de monde là dedans que c'est du monde
c'est qu'ils ont du pouvoir les gens
sont adultes
ces personnes là il ya s'abreuve de
leurs paroles puis une personne c'est
ces gens là vont abuser femmes en leur
pouvoir pour ces réducteurs de débit
fils aimé ton plus d'infos janvier là
dessus sauf que ça m'avait marqué
qu'inquiet adiba qu'elle dit est venu
suite c'est y avait dix quintaux du
pouvoir dit-il à la notoriété est
reconnue automatiquement cet accord du
genre de pouvoir qu'ils fassent l'effort
conscient de ne pas l'utiliser c'est
faux que consciemment ou restreignent le
train parce que sinon c'est ça c'est
trop facile de trop d'emprise sur des
sons déjà ça ne devrait pas être comme
ça répond on devrait pas de loterie mais
les gens c'est comme ceux de tout temps
je pense ceci c'est ce besoin là de
mettre sur un piédestal puis d'avoir des
idoles ça fait partie aussi des tirets
du grand narratif tous nos besoins des
cinémas gaumont encore il dit il disait
ça prend faut que tu puisses te
reconnaître dans quelques épis pour
aspirer verte amélioré de plaine
personnes au moins des modèles qui sont
là mais il n'y a pas de déraper non mais
pour vrai il ya tête de lecture
moi je conseillerais là qui m'ont marqué
mais cas nettement
je me rappelle pas exactement des dites
est exact de chacun faudrait que je les
relis en fait lors du vide de gilles
lipovetsky puis la culture du
narcissisme de christopher lasch qui
viennent vraiment répondra je trouvais
ce que tu racontes le faudrait que je
réalise on fait vraiment pas ce que je
trouve que ça ça résonne beaucoup dans
l'art actuel si je veux dire marie terme
or un bon ça c'est un exemple à mon avis
tu es même si elle faisait ça passe et
que j'étais rome était de 7 à cette
ascension là peut être dangereuse aussi
pis on dirait que c'est comme la chute
de nous deux qui se passe dans ce moment
si la chute de de toute cette ce fake lé
je sais pas si on voudrait qu'ils l'aps
la vérité ressort aussi puis j'ai
l'impression qu'on croyait en question
de plus en plus ses modèles puis parlant
de l'axé sur rien finalement qui sont un
peu leur duvet dans mon avis quand tu
parles d'humoristes qui viennent nous
dire comment parce que moi
c'est connu c'est peut-être qu'il
faudrait fouiller pourquoi sam chicotte
autant quelque chose mais mais par la
liberté d'expression pida disent
justement il était là il est question
est venu le jeu possède écoute et on a
parti justement sur l'épisode de
l'épisode de l'épisode de la tvq seppi
et j'ai même pas suivi c'est moi j'étais
dans la farine les clubs et riou il ya
eu trop qu'on traverse la forêt depuis
pitié il reste que jose intéressant
parce que tu es quand même dit la
liberté d'expression ça reste une valeur
je pense presque suprême noté pied on le
critiquait tantôt mettez lui disaient
les conséquence de restreindre la
liberté d'expression sont supérieures ou
aux bénéfices qu'on gagne de censurer
certains enfants bien sûr mais moi je
moi je suis pas pour cette can dance
hall que nul pas du tout en fait je
comprends je conçois jeu mais je n'y
adhère pas nécessairement puis ça dépend
des copies en passant c'est pas tous les
militants à mon avis qui demande de gm
peut donc en ciel et d'annuler la
participation à la vie publique de
quelques récits pour moi monté marques
amora on pensait que sa fille ne rien
dire aux tirs et 8 août des tribus
délaissées les diffuseurs qui ont été
froids et qui ont du bon qui ont été en
fait
inquiété par la situation qui ont décidé
de la retirer de la vie publique de lui
retirer ses sponsors et des rats mais
pour moi la solution à ce passe beaucoup
plus dans le dialogue que dans
l'annulation pure et simple parce que je
veux dire à la limite bon à quoi ça sert
finalement on coupe le dialogue c'est
comme cela et ce jeudi randonnée faut
discuter il faut en parler il faut
comprendre s'ouvrir puis je pense pas
que les militants demande nécessairement
d'annuler l'istia d'annuler
et la participation du team et on
mettons les propos de dutrizac par
exemple je trouve que tout se dommage je
trouve ça triste qu'en mettant à 2020
cette pensée le quai quelques records du
monde qui quitte la réflexion est rendue
si peu loin sur certains enfants puis
qu'il ya autant demande qui entendent se
pique nique adhèrent à ce je trouve ça
plate mais je trouve ça quand même
positif qui il ya eu le droit de le dire
qu'on a le droit
didier deschamps très petit rapporté
exactement fait c'est simple je pense
pour la démocratie et pour avoir un
véritable débat par contre si il ya un
humoriste qui donc est accusé
d'agression sexuelle je n'aurai plus
envie d'aller le voir en spectacle
j'aurais peut-être pas envie de lire ses
oeuvres mais mais bon c est ce que c'est
je pense qu'il va s'annuler soi même si
il ya quelque chose comme ça mais puis
après c'est correct aussi qu'il ya une
pression sociale pour dire bon ben ce
que ces spectacles peuvent être annulées
est-ce que l'or mais je pense est
importante de dialoguer quand même à
travers tous ceux ils cette colère est
légitime mais moi personnellement j'aime
mieux savoir que ça existe pour deux ans
il ya du chemin à faire que de fans non
non non taisez vous taisez vous dans un
existant ça fait partie de l'espace
public puis même si je suis pas d'accord
avec ça il ya peut-être une majorité de
gens qui pensent comme ceux qui dans le
fond mais bref mettons ces deux
personnes le 10 ne va se reposer mais en
tout cas on parle de ce jeu pas la femme
à qui le matin on exige qu'ils perdent
leur job
non sauf qu'ici mettons ne mettons
s'adapte pas où je sais pas le genre de
valeurs plus modernes ou chapeau comme
appelé seule pique et puis personne qui
qui qui a interpellé par ces propos
l'hôpital mais personne qui écoute puis
que mais qui ont encore un
microprocesseur
non mais c'est certes ces piquets qui
finalement
il anguille mais par leur jawad c'est
juste le problème si je pense que c'est
c'est qui ça des propos encore et
coutumes quelqu'un rompuy est qu il y
aurait pu les propos non plus mais je
pense que nourrit le sauter c'est la
folie le flou si je pense qu'il est
important de diversifier nos espaces
publics médiatique c'est fondamental
puis là il ya une pensée pour moi le
cube radio c'est comme mes paquebot
radio mais plusieurs médias
traditionnels bon ya une pensée
dominants qui fait partie de notre monde
qui compte en tant que terrain mais il
faut diversifier il faut avoir des
acteurs issus de différents milieux
moi j'ai envie de voir plus de
perspectives plus de couleurs +2 je suis
tanné de voir toujours les mêmes
vedettes on nous parle de jardinage
trousseau inintéressant mais je pense
que notre génération on n'écoute pas
vraiment la télé non pour cette raison
là je veux dire les shows de dt jets de
tarte chaud que je trouve dont j'allais
dire mon augmentant mais je veux pas
dire ça parce que ça serait de
l'angélisme
mais ça ne m'intéresse pas puis
j'aimerais mieux avoir accès à des gens
qu'on n'entend jamais tiens c'est encore
une fois c'est la richesse des podcasts
hamon ait de données la voix c'est pas
pour rien qu'on écoute moi les médias
peut-être traditionnels puis c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on écoute peu ce
qu'on regarde plus les médias sociaux
notre génération je pense qu'on veut
s'ouvrir c'est alors peut-être diversité
plus d'inclusivité plus de
représentativité c'est fondamental puis
j'ai hâte de lire le livre de marie
france bazzo là dessus même si j'adore
pas tous cas dix puis même si j'ai noué
ce bain parce qu'elle affirme haut et
fort qu'elle n'est pas féministe
il ya quelques années c'est pas grave
j'ai envie de m'ouvrir à son point de
vue la tuque
donc bref je pense que je pense que plus
d'inclusion c'est quand même une des
solutions mais tout à fait y faire
julie atteint occupation de brimades
avec att comme tellement ça tape tape
écoutez je l'écouterai mais ça paraît
tellement passionné non on n'a même pas
parlé daudet cette fois-ci l'eger bah
écoute falloir
il faudrait des actions c'est comme le
féminisme est exact merci puis j'ai
commencé le pas de castor vous prendre 5
je vous ai aimés mais je vous aime
encore merci nous sont barrés